hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it's a how well other sons last
week and the comments made by the
director of my crack mas been I've been
doing a little singing asking myself
some question like fuck about doing with
my wife just really I wanna be pathetic
loser so I do what I always do when I
get really depressed I watch all
nostalgic TV sergeant slaughter you
represent a simpler time when your last
name could also represent illegal war
crimes or when your biggest problem was
not collecting the latest action set
fight the good fight sergeant slaughter
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle pies I
remember when the line fresh from the
steward actually sounded appetizing is
this the only thing to bring me pleasure
just pure pathetic nostalgia
I'm a rack oh there there critic it's
not so bad so bad get out of here
fine fine I'm a dinosaur
fucking commercials what is it about
them that draws me to them they're so
conniving and yet so inviting it's like
they're in their own little world a
world that wants to be nice to you but
scam you at the exact same time
something about them strangely gives me
comfort I can actually watch these ads
all day actually it's not a bad idea
maybe I need to take a break from
nostalgic movies and nostalgic TV shows
and take a look at the stuff in between
I mean I loved commercials growing up
that got me excited for all the things
I'd pester my parents over until their
ears gushed with blood every time you
watch them you felt like you were making
it deal with them you buy their products
and then return to terror
your intelligence and physical health
it's a good trade how can such cunning
manipulation go unappreciated fucking
I'm gonna take this whole episode I'm
just gonna watch commercials yeah this
is a tribute to all the plastics
sugar-coated nonsense that we loved
growing up this is a segment I like to
call after these messages
I'm not gonna go in any order or time
together with any theme is just gonna be
commercials commercials commercials so
let's get started look we never got uh
Apple Jacks you remember these
commercials right it always starts off
with a group of kids eating the cereal
and some snooty know-it-all always ask
why they like eating if it doesn't taste
like apples just a good point why the
hell doesn't it taste like apples it's
like if cocoa puffs tasted like the old
brand it's kind of false advertising
Jeff on phone you mean avataq cool yes
but we'll see if he's cool by subjecting
him to the Apple Jacks s not the Apple
tracks turn juicy Applejack
stress-related Applejack should it taste
like apple red and white you foolin it
in line
let's choose choose wisely beta pill you
have chosen the project hero is part of
a complete breakfast and then they all
end with the kids taking a picture
together but my absolute favorite is the
caption at the bottom
Applejack's 94 somebody actually looked
at this picture and called it
Applejack's 94 as if to say yeah I
remember that summer that was the summer
of Apple Jacks the summer where anything
was possible the summer were boys the
cake men and girls became women I know
I've wrote it on a picture do you think
the kids from it did that like when they
all took that picture together they
simply labeled it the summer of Apple
Jacks 54 you know instead of the summer
up oh my god a killer Klown a fucking
killer Klown don't ever forget the
killer clown a killer clown double jack
cereal is part of a complete breakfast
[Music]
that was a clever idea there's a series
of sports balls that can be turned into
cuddly creatures
this raises a few questions though like
why were they playing with a furry
pillow like ball to begin with hey you
got our basketball oh wow that's a hairy
fucker it doesn't bounce in the
slightest
this'll do us well and then of course
when they go after the ball well shit
he's got a supernatural creature that
hasn't been discovered by science yet
but where's that darn ball also I felt
bad playing with these because I always
felt like I was giving the Popples a
migraine
I mean you're kicking them around
throwing them doesn't that hurt the pop
will swing come out like this they look
more like this but oh well you can't
fault it on still being a clutter
product okay I don't know what the fuck
this kid is on but I want a vanilla
cream any time people stoned out of
their minds don't laugh this hard
new giggles cookie two kinds of cream in
each funny face this end was
unbelievable this is like one of those
fucking epic commercials ever put on
television the ultimate challenge
[Music]
look at it's set in this apocalyptic
future where the fate of the world rests
in the hands of two kids who sit at the
table 4 marbles an even bigger marbles
it's like the world of Tron if it was
run by Lucas it's the most badass
commercial ever
[Music]
Santa has a very special Christmas
message he wants everyone to hear but a
long long time ago they used to have
hotlines for everything call one nine
hundred ninety-nine for three hundred
two dollars first made at forty five
cents each additional like that just two
dollars for the first minute and only
forty five cents every additional minute
it's pretty fucking costly for the 1980s
and santa needs your help to spread the
Christmas cheer be a Santa's helper yeah
I always remember you call him up in
some jerk off what talk as slowly as
possible so he could make sure that he
eats up your time and your fucking money
what a dick cock get your parents
permission to call Santa special phone
number now actually this takes on a
different meaning nowadays doesn't it
when you make a call that cost money
there's usually a different idea behind
it and the idea of Santa being a part of
that it's pretty freaking creepy gonna
Santa only if you get nostalgic whenever
you see this commercial over here it's
practically a staple of Christmas now
yeah boo did is just do
[Music]
your pebbles tis the season to be
sharing Fred
Happy Holidays power or food hey Fred
how can we celebrate Christmas if Jesus
isn't born yet - state your fucking
cereal get this when Nintendo was all
the rage they actually made a Nintendo
cereal yeah wasn't a Mario cereal or
Zelda cereal it was just Nintendo in
January what a weird idea it's kind of
like making internet the cereal isn't it
though it would probably be the first
seria where you have to be over 18 to
eat it and it wasn't just called
Nintendo cereal it was called the
Nintendo cereal system what the hell
does that do you really have to put the
word system at the end are we really
gonna confuse this Nintendo for another
Nintendo you're here you know you men
Nintendo the Entertainment System I
thought you meant Nintendo the
animatronic horse that only eats
toothpaste in circus midgets he's very
big in Sweden it was kind of cool
because it was technically two cereals
in one that means there were two bags in
each box I remember it was kind of a
pain once you open the bag you can't
really close it so if you open both of
them and poured it out you'll get double
the cereal all over the place maybe
that's why it didn't last so long
because half of it was on the floor
instead of a bowl well if I had Nintendo
on it you know we were gonna love it
anyway just like today fast-food joints
handed out toys with their kids meals
and sometimes you get a cup like these
he-man ones here at Burger King they
always told epic stories or at least as
much as they could being on a table but
here's my favorite part of this
commercial the kids get the Copts
and what do they do use them as swords
man those must be some pretty ghetto
kids I mean was a stick really too
expensive to use as a sword so you have
to use these were these your birthday
gifts right after they took you to your
party at the dollar store hardcore kids
really hardcore
I don't know what these kids problem is
but he cracks me up listen to him he's
taking funtime just a little too freakin
serious down kid you're building
sandcastles and Lincoln Logs you're not
a contracted construction worker why are
these kids even hang out with them all
he's doing is yelling out of all day
it's like a junior Sam Tennyson power
makes the crane and hardhats
each sold separately batteries not
included you from Revell hell yeah
transformers these were the coolest toys
out there even if we did take an hour to
figure out how the fuck they worked they
were still awesome and we loved every
minute of them the coolest one of these
commercials was the insecticons the
robots that look like insects
why because goddamn it I like to think
Tom Hanks influenced something in the
movie bigger yeah we heard his idea we
thought it was awesome and it kicked ass
to suddenly see these things around
something that used to be in every
transformer commercial was an awesome
but kind of creepy moment when the kids
would say the robots in disguise line
I mean it's cool but it's also pretty
freaky it's like the kid got possessed
by the devil or something your mother
sucks cocks in hell yeah I can't go
wrong with this game and then the song
it turns out was pretty catchy too if
you haven't played this game then you
have no childhood this game was
entertaining then and it's still
entertaining now if you're waiting for
the dentist and they have in the world
toy basket let's take out kind of a lame
joke they would do is that they would
find as many puns they could do with the
word for yeah those were good but let's
see how far we can really push what else
can you say but solid game with a salad
and connect more from Milton Bradley
[Music]
behold the most boring thing in the
entire friggin world I was fascinated by
kids who had she I bet you know how they
say something is so boring that they'd
rather watch grass grow
well nothing me the toy out of it they
made a toy out of watching grass grow
that's how bored apparently we got and
just look at this incredible selection
they have pia teddy bears puppies
kittens rams hold there's even a chia
tree tree they actually put a tree in
there it's alright
fucking tree does nothing except grow
and it's all three tons tickity a chia
pet the buttery that grows if you liked
it good for you but don't be surprised
if you have a sudden fascination with
chia paint drying and for the love of
God don't invite your friends over to
watch you will be pink
Papa bullshit this is micromachine
members anymore this guy is awesome he
started off as the FedEx man moved out
to a toy called micro machine which
simply I don't think exists
huija mini micro machine vehicles planes
opposed to the police station the marina
the mini motorcycle repair shop the gas
station the construction office work the
real working drawbridge highway passing
to wrapping garage doors
this guy is an advertiser's dream come
true he gets out all the information you
need
literally seconds the dramatically to
tell truth we trim replica of the real
thing that holds 25 micro machines with
fabulous fantastic features two totally
terrific elevators real working hoist
runway two cargo ones every time we came
on TV you felt like you were doing
ecstasy everything just seems so fast
and everything else moved in slow-mo
after he was done Penny's place that's
fit to get the deform precise micro
machine world calm tuned in thank god
this guy doesn't do audio books to be or
not to be that is the question whether
tis nobler in the mind to suffer the
slings and arrows of outrageous fortune
or to take arms against a sea of
troubles and by opposing end I just leap
No More and by a sleep to say we end the
heartache and the thousand natural
shocks that flesh is heir to tis a
consummation devoutly to be wished it
tonight just leap to sleep perchance to
dream
I there's the rub for in that sleep of
death what dreams may come the toys were
awesome and this guy was awesome
let's hope they both make a comeback
sometime soon remember it doesn't say
micromachines it's not the real thing
speaking of Awesome why the hell is
there no more ecto cooler in the world
this was like the coolest drink ever
and by God is the only good thing that's
not bubble Slimer ever produced I see
attaboy sly magician treat though
speaking of which what are we supposed
to assume that stomp it is I mean did
the best thing to come out of Slimer and
literally come out of Slimer oh my god
we could be drinking Slimer splooge he
already took looks like a giant sperm
it's like the sperm of sperm are cool I
don't want to think about it bastard
whatever it was it was incredible and
lasted a real long time but at some
point they discontinued it and by God
we're we pissed off
I keep hearing they're gonna make a new
Ghostbusters movie sometime soon and I'm
telling you right now if they do not do
a crossover with Ghostbusters three and
bring ecto cooler back somebody really
will be a fucking ghost and
[Music]
here's wet banana you can bask and flash
on wet banana like Billy yes be like
billion take a ride on the wet banana
yes dipping in sliding is a very good
thing to do with your weapon a very
special kind of gang but yes literary
wetland is guaranteed bananas 25 feet
long and the new web bananas do provide
30 feet long my body that's a fucking
big banana okay caution may hurt some
women down at Fraggle Rock why'd you
turn it off Chris why don't you read
something but the Fraggles are really
fun
ah yes the TV that actually encourages
you to read that's something you don't
see very often I'm so confident you
won't stop watching me that I'm just
giving you books
hahahahaha you can't read your diction
of me I won't die in - the Internet's
invented I got 10 more years suckers ha
ha ha ha
Oh God not one of these well you're a
hair commercial you might be able to
sell it if you stop now go it's fun to
help magic potty baby learn to use her
potty no it's not it's fucking gross
God and they say boys can be disgusting
you'll see you'll know words bet paddy
baby and her magic potty no water no
mess just pray that thing doesn't have
to go number two hello I'm the Nostalgia
Critic I remember it so you don't have
to well I got my recliner I got my eye
doughnut doughnuts teacher Don that can
only mean one thing our commercial
yeah I guess it is a weird idea to
review commercials but like I said
before they lived in their own little
world and there's so much fun to watch
and laugh at the 80s and 90s gave our
childhoods some really silly products
and even sillier ways of advertising
them to us and guess what we're gonna
look at them again today so welcome to
part 2 of a look back at nostalgic
commercials and sing but I like to call
we'll be right back figures that we
started a girls commercial yes they just
keep us from our lust of plastic weapons
[Applause]
yes you can do everything with it
drive-through glitter pick up dangerous
hitchhikers pose it against that curious
gigantic city backdrop that you have for
some reason it's a girl's dream come
true actually the fun thing I realize
about this is that if that car was a
little smaller it'd be a boy's toy how
weird is that
you think we'd be all about things being
bigger and stronger but no we like them
teeny tiny have you ever noticed that
girls got the huge convertibles we got
micromachines girls get the giant
detailed dolls we give the little GI Joe
action figures I mean at what point did
we look at TV and say fuck that tight
pussy convertibles this is a man's car
[Applause]
what was up with that girl's reaction
it's like she forgot she was supposed to
be impressed with the product she just
sounds so entranced - doesn't she it's
like off-screen the product suddenly
turned to an incredible superhero or
something - what else can you say but
Barbie Wow I am he-man call Shira and me
at one 900 another 900 number again as
if these didn't already have a sexual
slant by today's standards you honestly
have to put he-man in your ads now now
you're just doing the sexual undertones
in the sexual overtones fabulous stories
about what I may or may not be wearing
will be revealed to you when you hold a
lock your mighty phone and say
[Music]
we'll also tell you how to get an action
figure or this colorful poster part of
your $2 35 cent two-minute call to go to
local Science Museum's yes part of your
money will go to the Science Museum's we
haven't figured out yet how to make
change for a penny but we'll figure out
some percentage it's not easy when
you're new in town he's new so we hate
him except when you have something that
makes huge bubbles amazing bubbles we
shit that kid has bubbles bubble thing
makes people curious
[Music]
I was so wrong to judge you Billy how
can anything make bubbles as big as
giant as monstrous as bubble thing makes
[Music]
nobody seems to be able to resist the
kind of bubbles bubble thing makes it's
like my cruel abusive family doesn't
exist anymore
Thank You Billy you changed my life
forever
look at bubbles and what do they call
this incredible invention that brings
people together
bubbles face Wow what's the marksman guy
away from work that day product it's
like calling transformers changey things
or GI Joe's army and stuff or Hot Wheels
Union way to make us remember the
product guys bubble thing makes colossal
bubbles in its news from whammo hey what
you gonna do today Monty I'm gonna call
976 sent Jesus how many of these call
numbers were there this one doesn't even
look like it's try they're gonna tell me
a great story every day I'm gonna ask my
parents if it's ok if I call 9 7 6 7 7 7
nah me first me how much you wanna bet
this was just a local pedophile we got
in public access and want to hear
children's voices oh you want Sigmund $2
per call plus possible tool ask your
parents permission before calling Sega
challenges you with afterburner
oh hell yeah after prayer was awesome
accessories
the real dog bite excitement of the
arcade version you know the only weird
thing about this commercial is the
fantasies this kid has I mean they're a
little confused aren't they Wow I'm
playing a video game that makes me think
I'm in a cockpit playing a video game
yeah battle rolls nosedives supersonic
speed radar now if only you can convince
Hulk Hogan that doesn't have fucking
aliens in it only on the sega system
sega the challenge will always be there
the system will not hey girls looking
for something more needlessly
complicated than Joe Crowe are you that
little bitch that Owens needs to show
off to make yourself feel loved the kind
whose mother will threaten the coach's
family if you don't get a perfect score
this unnecessary addition to
overachieving physical perfection
yeah not to be fair maybe I'm being too
harsh I mean physical fitness is
important as long as you're not just
doing it to show when you just want to
show up oh god how did this toy never
catch on
listen to this these were spaceman who
take over the minds of dinosaurs and
used them as weapons in their
intergalactic war but evil rule on TV
show too but that never went anywhere
why I mean seriously it's like the best
combination of everything boys like
you're throwing cowboys ninjas pirates
and the annoying of girls for making us
feel confusing emotions and it'd be
perfect to shoot them all I guess a it's
as long as Jeff Goldblum has nothing to
do with them these dinosaurs awesome
tyrannosaurus rex with figures battle
gear and motorized booking action dying
[Music]
hey kids it's me the spring bunny call
me today oh come on that counts as a
reason to call a number because you saw
a fucking rabbit on screen there's a new
story every day so call today I mean how
easy Chinese hello kids I'm a tape would
you like to hear an exciting table
adventure
cuz you know tables go on a lot of
fucking adventures so if you like to
hear about me a table dial this number
table
we can't like to share our warm with a
fun and discoveries with you and
remember get your parents permission
before you die preferably while they're
asleep hey Fred it's the same old stick
again okay I'm sorry I gotta address
something with these commercials here
you got Barney what's going to these
extreme lengths to get Fred cereal why
doesn't he just go to the fucking store
I mean my god it's incredible the
lengths he'll go to I mean his face is
on the fucking box you think he'd be
able to get a few free ones everyone to
know why for that matter
why does Fred keep feeding into his
habit
what does me just crack and tell him
what he really needs to do bang oh this
rush got to roll okay Barney
um before I chase you around as some
comedic routine I just want to ask you
to do one thing look at yourself
just really look at yourself I mean my
god Barney my god you're a pathetic
wreck I mean that stage a lot how much
did that cost you hundred maybe
thousands of dollars and you take doing
this every week week after week your
blog your money away when you could be
spending time with your family this is
why you're defaulting on your mortgage
bond this is why Betty has to strip here
there's a $20 that's that's good for a
couple boxes don't come in the store get
up you enjoy yourself you have a problem
bond you have a real serious problem and
it needs to be addressed
I mean seriously bought what is it about
my cereal that sets it apart from other
cereals cuz it came from your wife's
books okay going down Travel cereal part
of this nutritious breakfast di dama
delicious
[Music]
maybe it's me but this seems ungodly
cool mr. turtle here's a classic it has
a great setup and a great punchline it's
a wonderful commercial ask mr. owl mr.
owl
how many licks does it take to get to
the tootsie roll center of a Tootsie Pop
let's find out one two three
sorry but you see I don't think that's
the real question here I think the real
question is why the hell is this boy
naked nobody addresses this even the
turtle when he first comes out is like
oh fuck put on some clothes boy I could
see your chunk mr. owl
how many lips to the cake get beer scene
I like is when the L opens his eyes I
don't know am I the only one that finds
that a little creepy mr. owl
let's find out well it's still a classic
commercial I always look forward to
watching it whenever it's up how many
licks does it take to get to the tootsie
roll center of a Tootsie Pop the world
may never know this is part of those
McDonald's commercials that try to
advertise to the teen demographic I
guess they were trying to make this a
household symbol yes this not only shows
that you can do 1/4 of the YMCA song but
also prove that your mother drank while
she was pregnant with you seriously how
the hell would you react if someone just
came up to you and did this nothing much
else you can say but do the arches
[Music]
monkey stuff really we're giving zelda
on the mythical story about a faraway
land a rap song
[Music]
and the powers in my hand it's not even
the worst it's just the idea of giving a
fantasy game a rap seems really silly to
me
I mean you know in Japan where the game
originated they probably treated with a
lot more respect
[Music]
well excuse me princess
it's the greatest thing okay yeah you
don't have to always say that TV and
movies are riding your brain there's
just too much violence why don't you go
play a board game or something yeah all
right take a look at this board
greatness game because killing things
that are smaller than you gives you
power
oh yeah you all know this game and all
have a great time yes what most kids
though I always want to take the game a
little further is your person Jewish
yeah you're history did you get as your
person slept with mommy is your person
serving time for multiple homicides yes
is your person the subject of several
disturbing documentaries yes good cards
do not actually talk if they do you
should probably seek help now at Burger
King you can collect see the animal
cards really
you went from he-man cups that you're
supposed to sword fight wit to
environmentally aware trading cards
there's seventeen cards in four albums
one with every kid's meal this is why
you'll never be as popular as happy
meals you can see women albums my heart
rate on with friends actual odds of
getting raped by a gorilla in the Burger
King now only one in five
oh yeah
remember these commercials are we
starting the mentally tormented kid who
has a fucking fetish for a children's
cereal it always starts off with some
kid discovering there's no corn pops and
then we take a disturbing look into
their deep dark psyche and if you were
out of corn pop out of my colored corn
pop you these kids are freaking nuts I
mean if you were watching this you think
it was something out of a scary film or
a psychological thriller or something
Pass me the corn pops weird xkt right
sir no I want my Kellogg's Corn Pops
go son coming go leave my corn pops are
you serious stay calm
Oh like sweet popcorn is never enough no
has a luggage bag on everything and shag
balls give it a head and see Summer Sun
well they get the pot is nobody nervous
yes you are tearing me apart for pops
Kellogg's Corn Pops is part of this
complete breakfast I gotta piss searches
high and low for fun food trees is the
fun fruit trees
I guess the idea behind these things was
that I don't know you make them laugh
and they drop fun fruit candies
that's why fun fruits are so much fun to
eat I don't know I always find these
things a little creepy I mean really
creepy
your fun fruit trees they just seem
unnatural every time they appear I keep
think they're gonna do something out of
an Evil Dead moon
fucking scam sub kiss fun foods
every chewy one is real rody fun oh boy
better enjoy this movie while you can
folks because you will never see it in
theaters again no one no male heir
ravaged back again on the big screen in
witness me happiest classic Barnaby
thong
did we mention that even though we're
just showing the enemy it seems they're
only about as long as this commercial
that's right the rest is live action and
dealing with incredibly slow-moving
racial relations doesn't that sound like
fun kids
where did you now playing at a theater
near you warning this Academy
award-winning movie Disney will soon be
ashamed of it may or may not be racially
insensitive honestly it's hard to tell
but just he's not gonna take that chance
anyway see the film that millions of
people around the world are calling okay
your grandma to win yeah they just
arrived introducing Cabbage Patch Kids
twins it doesn't happen very often
alright this is an ad for Cabbage Patch
Kids twins
[Music]
how is my Anna Marie
yeah it's innocent enough but look at
how this ad begins huh your grandma twin
yeah they just arrived no wonder for the
sake of argument she didn't know that
was a joke if your husband called up and
said that your daughter is pregnant
would you really your grandma Cabbage
Patch Kids twins they arrive together
with special adoption papers
how about Iraq your admin that they drop
a part of it
remember the Wuzzles these toys were so
popular they've got their own Disney TV
show and who can blame them it's a
pretty clever idea
these were toys that combine two kinds
of animals like half hippo and half
wrong with these except for one that was
okay really they couldn't come up with
something to rhyme with rule that's got
to be one of the easiest words to rhyme
I got one so I'm gonna snuggle so much
he can do see how it's incredibly easy
or how about I got a wazzle I'm gonna
snuggle we don't care about rhyming fire
shit oh it's still a clever idea either
way what elf commenting on the storybook
so flippantly from Hezbollah and the
weather for today will be Oh God this
boy is fucking nuts
that gathers Dorner Barrow storm what
hell is this kid it's like he's in the
lair of a Batman villain rapid-firing
Semyon magical turn that means six
arrows no waiting yes
no wait
that's why it's nothing and by nothing
me me it's nothing all right
aliens now we're talking it's the alien
queen gruesome gorillas ultimate space
marine sex
wait wait wait the ultimate Space Marine
is named a tax it sounds like discount
tampons you get at the dollar store tax
disguised in his big bad bug suit
oh really an alien disguise suit why
didn't they think of that before
all right Marines here's the plan we are
going to dress up in alien costumes get
a bunch of garbage bags and the world's
biggest dildos and we are gonna sneak
into the aliens nest they don't have any
eyes so they'll never be able to spot us
any questions yes let's how do I get out
of this chickenshit outfit sure send Ian
Hickson the heavily armored evac fighter
blast yeah
and my mom yes and bodily yes of course
alien costumes and bottling this is the
future of our military folks if this is
how it's gonna look
I think Hudson said it best hi my buck
each sold separately
you've got your sunrise
you caught a prize you're making your
Johnson what you caught a prize you're
making your Johnson
what pardon Knights summer whites you
your friends and your Johnson Johnson
Saturday nights distant lights do your
girl in your Johnson Bo hey keep it
clean disturbing commercials get any
creepier than that lose the tails water
trails do your kids in your Johnson
you and your Johnson a way of life for
over 50 years and then your wife found
out what you were doing with your
Johnson and well let's just say you and
your Johnson will be hanging out with
any kids anymore which was like this do
make you wonder though are they aware
what's going on no I almost think they
planned this so that people will talk
about their products more like they
meant for it to have a double meat but I
don't know maybe I'm sounding like a
conspiracy nut I mean can you think of
any other commercial that can be taken
the wrong way so easily just when you
see what I've got it's the Wunder boner
the Wunder boner you laugh now just
watch he's just assemble the Wunder
boners stainless steel rods like this
take fish and
the Wunder boner introducing the Wunder
boner the amazing new fishing tool that
makes deboning fish agrees okay you have
to know you're talking about nobody's
that naive you're trying to play all
innocent when you know that everyone's
gonna be snickering at your commercial
and thus remembering your product better
I mean I might believe that it wasn't
intentional if they don't drop any more
innuendos the Wunder boner my wife would
like that no you totally know what
you're talking about it you should be
ashamed of yourself well might make the
Wunder boners a women don't say that I
don't care of your wife with like one of
those just keep your fucking what a
boner to yourself the Wunder boner comes
with a polyethylene storage case that
doubles as a base and a cutting board I
mean seriously you can't even say that
word without having somebody crack off
watch wonderpana
[Applause]
you see
so uh hey did you get the wonderpana
buddy you should order your Wunder boner
down oh all right kids
fucking Wunder boner - I draw the line
this was my look at commercials part two
I hope you had a lot of fun thanks for
joining me and I hope that you your
Johnson and your Wonder boner have a
fantastic evening I'm the Nostalgia
Critic end oh really
hey kids you want to waste some time you
must if you're watching one of my videos
it's time to review some cash all yes
the commercials of the 80s and 90s are
back here to give us that joyfully
akward world of colorfully selling out
of tickets
Oh enjoy these bring even the worst ones
can manage to summon a smile to a
nostalgic mind I love them I love them I
love and we're gonna look at them again
today so seeing how one special was
called we'll be right back and another
one was called after these messages this
one I'm gonna entitle explanation point
[Music]
it's here the et or game at last no you
can pretend to help ET called home and
sometimes you can fly really we're
including flying in a board game now you
know moving from square to square
doesn't technically count as flying hmm
move two spaces sometimes you can fly
Wow indeed easily impress a little boy
danger sometimes you can hide spaceship
the one that helps you get to the most
winners loser has to play the video game
[Music]
you know I see no reason to make a board
game on ET this commercial does manage
to capture the magic and drawn-out
boredom of the original ET board game
from Parker Brothers also sold
separately the ET card game oh yeah I
want to see ET in a card game
no it didn't some are simply required
oh great morph in the world's ugliest
pin cushions having breakfast your
squeeze your hand you sadist whoa okay I
guess her shockwave kiss solved
everything I think I just I've never
forgot that about girls toys why would
you want a baby to cry all the time
I mean laughing or giggling okay that I
understand but crying that's a royal
pain this is just what I've wanted to do
ever since I was a little girl and I
guess as is the way of things you give
birth and raise a little girl so you can
immediately prepare her from childhood
to start doing the same thing hey if I
raised a kid who didn't blink and look
like a deflated potato I don't think I'm
win parent of the year I love this
commercial because you literally have no
idea what it's advertising until they
just say it
[Music]
all you know is that whatever it is it
gives you a great lust for life great
guy great nuts of course because when I
think of appreciating all the miracles
that life has to offer I think of a
cereal that tastes like cardboard and
feels like shitting Beatles Post great
nut cereal you know when you've got it
good yes clearly this is a woman who has
a good she's on vacation in a log cabin
all by herself no friends no family
sipping the last drop of the most boring
cereal the world has ever created
clearly this is the closest thing to
nuts that she's ever gonna get to touch
[Music]
comparing our new hands waistband but
due to the Loom training because this is
who you trust with your underwear right
guys a bunch of aging old lesbians who
like to snap your band like it's a
prostitute's bra strap now seriously I'm
all for women in the work world but
isn't one guy in there it feels a little
odd here hold it let know our comfort
we've waistband fits better for one
thing it's stronger
I mean how would you like it if nothing
but men were looking at women's
underwear all day hey dumb get over here
feel this bra come I feel this problem a
night yeah and that night a good bra
good bra yeah I like this bra really
nice bra
softest well very nice very soft very
pink there thank ya like flowers yeah
pretty flower like a petunia you know I
think but doing I'd say more like a
buttercup no more like a d-cup yeah man
I could touch this thing for hours hours
plenty hours hours hours well I guess if
the Hanes fits wear it
Hagen's wins the battle of the bands
that's why we put our name on it
Eames fits better than finger food we
need to get laid
it's new cool a cooler with 20% Julie
what it's new kool-aid coolers with 20%
Julian this is Jews that's 20% juice
whoa what the hell's in the rest of it
that's right kids 20% juice it also
includes 50% corn syrup 20% yellow
number 5 and 10% God we don't know what
but the FDA was asleep drink it while
it's still unidentifiable it's just so
happy about it too it's a really worth
celebrating that 1/5 of your product is
actually what you say it is it's a
little disturbing it's like advertising
Pepsi
now with 20% soda and 80% rusty nails or
Quaker Oats
now with 20% oh it's an 80% Donald
Rumsfeld though if chicken McNuggets can
make a big deal about having actual
white and meat chicken in there I guess
anything's worth celebrating
ah yes Zack our favorite Lego maniac
[Music]
here's a Lego
or was it jack
[Music]
is it Jack or Zach here it's Bell Zach
but in this commercial you definitely
hear a Jane his name is Jackie's new in
town lunchtime is what he gets down in
fact is that even the same kid my god
it's let me just produce these children
in the same factory they make child
singers this scent is cosmic leaked to
Mars he's out there cruising with the
Stars his mine is lost in outer space a
Legoland basket case so obviously there
was a ton of commercials based on this
legendary Lego maniac but it does make
me wonder what this iconic toy God among
children went on to do I mean where do
you think he is right now he's grandma's
houses where he stays it's been ten
years since he's been laid and 35 is
well Direk collecting unemployment
checks he still obsessed with Lego see
it gets much talk in therapy he checks
his list off every day on bullies he
will blow away Zach Zach he's a psycho
maniac Zach Zach Keith
well we'll still remember you in this
timeless commercial and the most likely
unhealthy obsession you probably have
[Music]
legoland king's castle airport cosmic
fleet Voyager sold separately from lego
systems has anybody noticed that the
Ghostbuster toys were some of the most
creative toys ever made
friggin awesome Terry true and as you'd
imagine they were advertised well too
but I have to admit there's one part
that just rubs me the wrong way get a
moist ghost funny guys watching scream
[Music]
am I the only one disturbed that that's
possible anal rape I mean it's not like
we didn't see the ghosts in the movies
do something like this so I find it very
unnerving funny guys watching scream
hey my body would do that - if Boo Berry
was doing me from all sides and now
because I don't know any better the top
ten out of context Ghostbuster lines
that go with this commercial there's
something you don't see every day I have
seen shit that'll turn you white you're
not sleeping with it are you right
you're scaring the straights he slimed
me I think they're more interested in my
epididymis we get this guy laid we won't
have any trouble why am i drippings with
pool you don't want us exposing
ourselves and the number one best out of
context Ghostbuster line to be
associated with this commercialism
that's a big Twinkie plenty of pong
[Applause]
so despite the fact that this scene is a
little risque that Ghostbuster toys were
some of the best toys out there and the
commercials always showed it oh this is
what you do with your spare time yep I
think every kid at some point had a
lite-brite I don't know what it is maybe
it's the jingle maybe it's just a cool
idea but everybody remembers this toy
and of course every single kid in the
entire world did the exact same thing
yeah made dirty pictures with it don't
act like you didn't do this every little
kid did boobies penises and anything
else we thought was naughty made it onto
the lite-brite screen it was like the
kids version of Craigslist nothing but
perversion as far as the eye could see
[Music]
my personal favor is when they used it
to spell out words but it was always
nice stuff like happy birthday or here's
Susie couldn't use it for more inventive
scenarios make a baby
even if we didn't always use it
correctly lite-brite was and always will
be a pretty cool toy and this is a
pretty cool commercial to go along with
it light bright from Milton Bradley hey
it's the continuing Adventures of sugar
bear kids nowadays may not know this but
cereal commercials back then were
actually sort of like well cereals they
were soap operas with cliffhangers and
lingering storylines half of the
commercials always ended in to be
continued
and it was sugar-coated awesomeness but
by far one of the weakest ones has to be
with sugar bear just take a look now
we're turning the tables on you lose a
super golden cross well gee what the
fuck do you thinks gonna happen golly
could it be like every other commercial
where he just eats the goddamn cereal
and saves the day is that even a
possibility you can solve the mystery
with I can pack sugar bear flip books
look at it they just showed you what
happened they don't give a shit they
know that we know so might as well just
come out and display it I mean is it
even worth going through the flip book
to see what happens I mean we all know
what the outcomes gonna be go the last
page we all know what it's gonna
Jesus I don't care I still love sugar
bear and I look forward to him kicking
some more ass with his laid-back
attitude but Jesus pop-tarts commercials
were always the staple of the 80s and
90s with this retro fashion and retro
music and of course that confusing is
hell tagline how can something be so hot
it's cold or so cold it's hot it's like
saying they're so great they suck they
suck so it's great I never got it it's
like one of those n riddles you're never
supposed to really figure out what is so
hot it's cool but it's so cool it's hot
[Music]
pop-tarts you can get ready for
something wild when you bite into new
Kellogg's pop guys explosive radiation
those things are fucking around let me
only took your head off
I think bits of her brain just flew out
there Lindsay why are you late for class
parts for taste is better than ever in
producing Leatherhead now we're talking
teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle toys always
a favorite yeah these are your targets
the Friends of the Ninja Turtles yo
Socky your jumbo yo Socky your jumbo you
sucky your Jimbo it sounds a little
pervert actually even Leatherhead sounds
a little dirty it sounds like the name
of a gimp from an S&M dungeon now you
can get a pop-up display stand inside
specially marked packages of Turtle
figures great for displaying Turtles
when they're not eating pizza we just
thought we remind you that the turtles
ate pizza as much as I love the turtle
toys and the commercials there was
always one thing that drove me nuts they
never got the same voice for shredder
the voice for shredder in the
commercials was never the same voice as
from the show I mean they didn't even
try I'll take care of them once and for
all
that sounds nothing like the original
shredder hey while they're at it why
don't they go with this voice they
betrayed me but didn't keep very promise
they tricked me and I don't care anymore
whoa better watch me old blood pressures
redhead you're just a little chicken
cheap trip trip trip to Gigi
how is your sex life great for
displaying Turtles when they're not
eating pizza from playmate bitch baby
the Barbies cats notice how the Barbie
in no way involves bending your arms or
legs Oh God even that was too
complicated for the doll to do for the
dancing toy could you allow just a
little bit more movement outside of the
I'm trying to step on a bug while I have
a headache move god I need aspirin now
the Barbie has club t-shirt and video
with a special appearance by Paula Abdul
oh now that would be interesting oh
honey I just don't think you're very
cool allottee suicide - what's that
awful she's just a gob orphan constant I
think she should kiss later doing
Seacrest speeders oh my god I hated
these things anyone who had these you
got gypped okay so these cars don't run
unless you put these spotlights on them
there's your problem why would you want
to do that what are these solar powered
cars who thought this up so that means
every time you put the light on it it
moves a centimeter and you have to have
that stupid light on the whole entire
time or it doesn't move and trust me
it's a lot harder than it looks
you get to move a centimeter then
another centimeter and aim for the
goddamn thing away super tight on curves
oh and you got those bridges where it
always got stuck yes why because the
fucking light ones shine through so you
always had to push it with your fucking
toe or something god I hated this toy
take off with
the liable shaft future is he so hot so
cool batteries not included not for use
with some cars you put it together from
the tail right transformers now the
great sir plank is classic pretenders
wait what wait there people now another
robots the dinosaurs - what hey now the
cars what wait how is this classic I
don't remember this like why are they
people I don't get that who are they
well they leave everything up by that
show and tell time I'm having anything
that candy ramos cantina hi my name is
Teddy Ruxpin can you and I be friends
why are alphabets fun to eat because you
can eat here's a fun game to play at
home count all the phallic symbols
[Music]
don't
don't eat
[Music]
new pretender transformers are here oh
these things again okay let's see if
they explain it any better
[Music]
look there are evil Decepticon tenders
too finally we have found a cure for
diabetes what I can't wait for the day I
make that announcement geez for over 16
years I'm sorry you lost me
you totally lost me at that fake out I
don't carry you're promoting if you know
what I'm gonna give five people diabetes
right now yeah it's the critic inject
them no just a little side project I got
go ahead Oh God I might be horrible
introducing slim suit just put it on to
take weight off okay get ready for the
dumbest thing you have ever seen who'd
ever think I could lose weight while
watching TV you believe we're losing
weight just by talking on the phone no
no I can't in fact I'm going to call
lying on that just put it on to take
weight off it's that easy no kidding the
slim suit can help you lose weight by
doing absolutely nothing when does it
take off like an ounce of weight a week
or something six hours ago I was
absolutely panicked because this dress
was too tight so I knew to wear my
swimsuit and now my dress fits perfectly
really six hours of wearing the slim
suit can make you go down an entire
dress size that's incredible I mean all
you other idiots out there we're trying
to exercise or eat right and with
amazing slim suit one size fits all yeah
especially for people trying to lose
weight like this got most one size will
fit most yes everyone can look great in
swimsuits look at this girl you know
she's got a date to the prom it's simple
the more active you are the more
swimsuit works for you oh the more you
exercise the more slim suit will help
you lose weight yeah it's pretty subtle
that way it's almost as if you don't
need it at all it's the shape up plan
you don't have to hassle with just put
it on to take it off take it easy or
take it to the max professionals also
recommend these magic beans mixed with a
placebo brought to you by the tooth
fairy when you're in Oz for everyday
wear or every night you can actually
wake up weighing less no harmful pills
or starvation diets and all you had to
do was sacrifice your fucking common
sense because of the incredible demand
for slim suit supplies are limited yeah
we only made five of these because we
thought only five people would be dumb
enough to buy it you proved us wrong
America so order now to put slim suit on
to take weight off your slim suit comes
complete with the pounds off program at
no extra charge
wait what program you said all we have
to do what sit on our asses what is
there a time scale that's sitting on our
asses plumps networks I lose weight
every time I wear it thanks to some suit
I actually lost weight while sleeping it
truly is the work of an artist perhaps a
con artist if you will well folks I
don't think I'm gonna top this fit of
insanity so might as well just call it
whiskey
thanks for joining me on my commercial
special mmm
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember Zach
he's a psycho maniac Zach Zach Jesus Ike
go maniac bitch Chips Ahoy there's new
sprinkle Chips Ahoy yep it's that time
again to tore down the often forgotten
but fondly remembered avenue of
nostalgic commercials why do so many
than stay with us what is it about the
world of pandering and advertising that
makes us so fond of our whatever it is
we're gonna review them and partake in
their corniness once more so see how the
first one I called we'll be right back
and the second one after these messages
and the third one explanation point this
one I'm gonna call the fourth
[Music]
ah good old chef boyardee causing
children around the world to grow up and
shout I can't believe I used to put this
in my body dinosaurs from Chef Boyardee
tastes wholesome pasta that's a dinosaur
hunt tasty wholesome pasta I can think
of three things wrong with that sentence
thank goodness new pac-man pasta from
Chef Boyardee
no of course making famous characters
into edible shapes is nothing new there
was pac-man Smurfs help even take TechEd
Ogata pasta what some people forget is
that for the longest time they tried to
make a game out of eating their products
yeah listen and when you get three x's
or rows of your spoon you win because
first ones that captured all three
dinosaur shapes wins
why must you turn dinnertime into a
competitive sport when the more
appropriate rules be hey kids if you can
eat the elbow macaroni and ketchup we're
calling pasta without vomiting it up
through your ears nose or mouth you win
look at this crazy kid he is jacked up
on the stuff just look at face it's like
he saw Jesus and at the same time
decided he wanted to eat him sexism nose
makes me
Decco they're so tasty well even if you
don't like the food Chef Boyardee always
knew how to give us that tasty amount of
goofiness tic tic tic tic tic tac toe
with and without meatballs Oh Oh God
you can't help but feel that warm fuzzy
feeling whenever you watch this classic
[Music]
really it's a McDonald's commercial
about a little girl thinking about
running away and for some reason never
questions the creepy clown that's on our
neighbors lawn McDonald and that's where
I'm from I hear it's a dictatorship
where people disappear a Lindsay maybe
there's some undesirables there holding
back genetic progress I hear where
you're from is really nice too it's so
calm cuz you got that basketball hoop
over your garage and your back porch has
that great wind chime
once there's that beautiful feel yeah
but to be fair her basketball hoop and
wind chime aren't as impressive as your
satanic powers to levitate solid man's
and create life from nothingness
McDonald land is still sounding a bit
cooler there Ronald who's gonna make the
decorations for your dad's birthday
party who's gonna be the snowflake in
the school play I was gonna feed mr.
goldfish okay yeah it all seems sweet
and cute until you realized this was a
stranger danger commercial come on give
me the first person to think that about
Ronald McDonald I mean look at him in
this commercial
[Music]
Krim yeah if a strange man dressed like
a clown lures you with magic tricks and
oh I don't know offers you McDonald's to
go with him
chances are you should probably run for
home or that's not like puts it yeah get
out of it just look at the way Ronald
stares at her in this scene if someone
went up to your kid and smiled like this
I pull her the fuck away from him oh
well as much as I make fun of them I
still love both these commercials around
Christmastime McDonald's wishes you a
holiday season with the people who make
you smile
brought to you by a company set to
sabotage your arteries for the rest of
your life by Lindsay so you think
celebrity endorsements are bad now take
a look at what they did to the Caped
Crusader when Batman Returns came out
that's right is he gonna stop rioters or
capturing the culprit responsible for
this crime fuck no he's gonna get him
some diet coke Tyco tire coke I need my
tire car
don't try to get out of the way I made
my bet free alternative to high-fructose
deliciousness
[Music]
mr. Pelletier saya what we discover it
was Catwoman who was the culprit all
alone boy slow leak for her isn't it I
mean was this really her grand plan shut
down the city so she could tease
Batman's bizarre low-calorie soda fetish
no offense Selina but you could do
better that's the last reason anybody
drinks it the first reason is well now
honestly because Batman tricks it he
loves it so much he would literally let
the city die just to get the last one
that's probably the best endorsement you
could give a product so I guess it works
[Music]
another classic collection of
commercials we can't forget along with
that wonderful jingle that we can't
forget their trauma commercials and all
but is it me or does this sound like the
national anthem for adults who never
really did grow up you know those man
children and women children who never
want to do anything with their lives
except play with their toys I'm telling
you it's all because of this jingle
don't believe me the sequel commercial
that came out years later proves it
they're in the exact same location
the toys-r-us cared for so much you
really fast really it's like no time has
passed they never left their parents
place this is their life
it's the biggest toy store in fact the
more I think about it they're probably
there even to this day Reggie go away
mom
Reggie Winnie I gotta get a job I told
you mom I'm a Toys R Us kid you keep
saying that you couldn't possibly
understand mom I've never gotta have any
grandchildren they just complicate the
plan mom the toys-r-us plan I'm going to
watch old old movies of you and see
where I went wrong Toys R Us cake mom
Toys R Us kid the only other problem I
ever had with these commercials is that
half the toys were never at Toys R Us
you ever noticed that I don't know if it
was a copyright thing or what but half
of these products they were advertising
we're never at the store like imagine
you were a ninja turtle not like I was
look at these fucking things holy shit
I want the life-size dancing ninja
turtles please
don't have it okay I'll take that
gigantic teddy bear that he's bouncing
around on well how about that game where
you bombed the battleship game where you
can bomb a battleship this place is an
insult to Joffrey the giraffe Critic
honey I gotta get a job
with shoe could be marshmallow Beth
believe it or not there was actually a
period of time when Count Chocula was a
live-action character and would you like
to see what he looks like
if you chuckling how is that it's like a
silly putty combo of the Nesquik rabbit
and fat weird al' yankovic and okay that
chin seriously needs to be censored I
swear I'm looking at Forest Whitaker's
testicles right now and that should not
be under the mouth of any cereal mascot
something I don't even know what the
commercials about it's a monster that
wakes up but when he's fed Count Chocula
he turns back into a kid who cares I
can't take your eyes off that image of
Robin Williams face coming out of a
Muppets but if you turn it away turn it
away burn it with acid send the spies a
chocolate monster give no time what a
monstrously good part of a complete
breakfast Count Chocula can satisfy the
chocolate monster in you you stay the
fuck away from my chocolate monster you
know you're doing a great job oh yeah I
don't know how many people remember this
one but for a while everybody was
quoting it it starts off with a woman
working at her job when her boss
obviously starts hitting on her but
you're not using all your assets with a
body like that you can go to places
sexual harassment makes you feel like
less of a person
Aska stop sexual harassment booklet at
your public library be a little more
sexy talking about your job you know
we're talking about sexual harassment
here and I don't have to take it boom my
early 90s perm just schooled your ass I
don't know what it is there's just
something about how direct she is and
how almost robotic she says it no we're
talking about sexual harassment here
[Music]
the funny thing is sometimes I wonder if
this would still work if the roles were
reversed like he feels the woman hitting
on the man my guess at almost he would
be no for one kind of obviously this
happens more to women that does to men
but to men just aren't smart enough to
recognize when they're being hit on
we're kind of dumb that way if a woman
is not interested that's the one we go
for but a woman is interested
we're blindly naive to it for some
reason if a female boss is hitting on a
male worker he's not gonna catch on to
it anytime soon
except for you you come here yes my lady
it's been a long day hasn't it Oh EO
henchman number 5 yes my lady and you do
anything for me
what of you yes my lady unless someone
have heretofore to kill you in which
case I was swearing allegiance to our
blind okay what do you say I ride your
broomstick for a while
what do you mean fill my pointy hat
don't follow flipper totally lost Jesus
whatever spell it out for you I want to
have sex with you Oh
I don't have any other words to say not
one part of that sentence could be
interpreted any other way oh I think I
see what you're saying
good you want me in henchwoman number
twelve to hook up and don't worry my
lady I'm still working on it
hello henchwoman number 12 still not
into you creep she's so into forget it
you're fired
I'm gonna go hit on a flying monkey I
need a better Union enjoyably awkward
and quotable as hell we're just talking
about a damn funny commercial here no
we're talking about sexual harassment
here and I don't have to take on sexual
harassment violates you and it violates
the law remember kicks the only cereal
commercial that pretty much listed every
single reason why not to buy it there's
no candy stuff no sugar sprinkles no
preservatives no colors it doesn't have
any candy or chocolate in it honestly
it's just rabbit droppings that they
painted yellow but the box is pretty
actually they went so far out of their
way to prove how little is in it that
there's actually a commercial that says
there's no flavor in it
listen no cars okay Liz yeah that might
be taking the wrong wait guys especially
when you're advertising how phenomenally
boring your product is the ones with
little candies bag the funny thing is
that kicks is the only cereal that
tastes different literally with every
single bite you take it's like it gets
worse and worse with every single nip
I'm not even joking you can do a diagram
on the natural progression of what every
bite does to your taste buds
the first bite demonstrates a tasty
enjoyable experience that seems rather
satisfying
notice how the smile has deteriorated by
50% on the second bite signifying less
enjoyment out of the experience the
third by clearly shows the mistake one
feels having placed this product in
their mouth surely part of the Box must
have worked its way onto the spoon
clearly they've made a cereal out of
packing peanuts this mistake will not be
made again now kids can get a classic
little golden book free from cakes with
one proof of purchase plus shipping okay
did anyone ever actually send in the
proof of purchase I mean did that ever
happen in the history of mankind
I don't know cereals don't do this but
when they were too cheap to put the toy
in the box they had you pay for a stamp
an envelope as well as shipping and
handling and have the toy delivered to
you a few days later do kids really have
the attention span for that now kids can
get it free dr. Seuss classic to read
with two proofs of purchase plus
shipping but to be fair those books
probably would taste better than the
actual cereal yes contested mother
approve uh yeah let's say it like it is
people kicks kids tolerated mother has
coupons hey kids
there's another turtle rific edition of
now we're talking Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles this is just a straightforward
and promoting the first VHS that ever
came out of the series heroes in a
half-shell here's not a time to talk
about except for one little portion that
might throw you off a bit the video that
reveals the incredible true story wait a
minute well with that the video that
reveals the incredible true story the
incredible true story mmm I'm not a
scientist or anything but I'm just gonna
take a wild guess that the insane
Adventures of four anthropomorphic
life-forms living in the sewer escape
board eating pizza and fighting the
ninja army led by Uncle Phil probably
probably
takes place in the world of fiction it's
just so strange because there's no other
way you can interpret it it's not like
he meant it to be taken this way or a
part of some misunderstanding no they
straight up say it's a true story the
video that reveals the incredible true
story what the hell are we supposed to
do with that except drop a conclusion
that FTE are fucking liars the video
that reveals the incredible true story
that's right
they're real if you don't see him in
front of you right now it's probably
because you haven't bought enough of our
products would we lie what I like too is
that the announcer clearly has no
problem straight up lying to kids about
it but he almost stumbles when he has to
read what they're actually called it's
teenage new people into Turtles as if
half way through he just realized how
stupid this sounded but tried to keep
going anyway Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles still phone ahead just don't
have fh e testify in court anytime soon
now this next one's a classic for to
read oh I see you're a man who likes
Donuts eh yeah well what do you say we
find your creamy Center what do you mean
do some old punching don't let something
rise up Dalila what's wrong with you I
want weird wobbly which sticks oh you
want me and the actress from Game of
Thrones when the plays they'll by no
Ragan chick to hook up well don't worry
I got her on speed dial
hey you know Joey wants me what am I
missing here you stole that will you
piss off and try to review some
commercials commercials yeah with this
one
[Music]
and this is what happens when a man and
a woman love each other very very much
they look at porno sites together
you're fired I don't even know you
speaking of where babies come from we
got possibly one of the most brutally
honest baby doll commercials ever
they're called to take care of me twins
even the title sounds a little angry
doesn't it like a bitter nickname or
something
this commercial seems determined to show
every stressful terrible part about
raising a child this is my day again
not the happiest words to shout during a
baby commercial but this is like the
most passive-aggressive ad I've ever
seen like saying oh yeah you want a baby
you want a fucking baby to kiss your
social life goodbye because this is your
day this is your entire goddamn day
that's just drooling sneezing feeding
changing running around just look at the
smile she gives that's the smile of I'm
about to kill these little bastards if
someone doesn't take him away from me
take care of me
[Music]
and oh boy what a rushed happy ending
huh hell hell hell hell hell but it's
really goodbye here between speak for
baby sounds I don't think I've ever seen
a toy that advertised more why not to
buy it
but hey if tearing out your hair to
raise a not human being is your idea of
fun then ah yet another series of
classics the setup is that we see what
happens to a scrawny looking kid if they
keep growing up while drinking their
milk
what girl's gonna go for me with a body
like this hang in there tom
I'm you 2 years from now cuz you're
drinking milk and working out NewsView
big brother I'm drinking milk and in the
next few years it's gonna give me a lot
of what I need for strong bones
beautiful skin and a healthy body
looking closer at these people realized
how phenomenally shallow they are I mean
all of them are totally based on looks
alone in fact one of them even flat-out
says it but I'll bet you're hoping for a
hunk and when all my work is done
will you love me just for my body I can
live with that milk it does a body good
milk because personality should come
never as long as they show looks are
everything I guess milk is the ultimate
ace in the hole
my body the only difference between me
and the guys is this dress hey you can
see we turned out just fine
[Music]
yeah he beats me with a shovel but you
could skate on those ABS if you're still
the same little creep in a big body my
brother the truth is if we really could
go into the future based on what these
selfish little douchebags are like they
probably wouldn't like what they see you
may think I'm a shrimp now big brother
but I drink milk which means like our
long hair beautiful skin and become
totally self-absorbed meaning I want me
to think for myself and instead marry a
wealthy millionaire who only wants me
for my body and then I'll feel this
emptiness inside that only the miracle
of cocaine can cure but that's not
enough so that I'll turn to heroin
but then we'll discover rehab and
realize it was all word of god's plan
with my only friend the glass of milk
that started it all milk what the fuck
hey this is my spot maybe I'm reading
too deep into it or maybe they should
emphasize the importance of brain power
as well as Bobby power milk it does a
body good oh good a commercial from
Canada our friendly neighbors from the
north they're always so kind and
everything they do oh look a baby shower
for an expectant mother oh you got the
little girl there and everything oh my
god this is gonna be adorable it's a
rape whistle what the fuck Canada I mean
talk about an uncomfortable blow to your
nads is this how you do all your serious
commercials start off with something
innocent and light-hearted and then
smash it down in a cruel cruel reality I
mean it's like starting up an ad like
this you know the hard day's work
doesn't call for water out of the cooler
what do you got there I got me a nice
bottle of mountain water cool refreshing
big on taste but also big on
satisfaction what do you got there I got
pancreatic cancer
sheesh I mean this can't be good for
tourism who the hell would want to go to
Canada after learning that statistic do
they have that on the entry sign to the
place
welcome to Canada one in two girls will
be physically or sexually abused
that's pretty awkward I mean how do you
think the expecting mother feels that
it's a rape whistle well grandma just
ruined the baby shower
I'm gonna go hit the vodka don't wait
can't drink that's right that's right
again great timing grandma I know you
mean well guys but Jesus it's a rape
whistle everyone rise for the greatest
commercial ever
I know it's current but trust me when I
say it is destined to become a nostalgic
commercial classic it starts off with a
guy just going into a Denny's to get
some pancakes what follows is a moment
of pure and absolute beauty red white
and blue pancakes huh they taste like
America
[Music]
yes yes they do not extrange old man
Denny's red white and blue pancakes
taste like America my god everything
this country stands for all the
bloodshed all the cries of freedom for
all the wars all the battles all the
patriotic treasures of the world Oh what
found here in this pub brilliant piece
of brilliant miss you know some people
say they see America and the Lincoln
Memorial fuck them
some say they see it in the Constitution
of the United States but then to some
say they see it in our purple mountains
Majesty in the glimmering eye of the
honest worker or in Our Stars when they
see that our flag is still there in
pussy panties these are the red white
and blue pancakes from Denny's I mean
just look at this man when he walks in
he is lost and unsure of himself he is
afraid to venture where he has never
ventured before it is these pancakes
these simple red white and blue pancakes
but where were they leaning but what
will this mean for his future but then
you can see the old man thinking
thinking long and hard about it do I
tell him
do I let him in on the secret of this
nation's greatest landmark yes he is
ready
[Music]
[Applause]
merica and you can see on that young
man's face that he has found salvation
so he once was lost but now has found
Dennis red white and blue pancakes
tell me Oh kind wise sir what other
words of wisdom you have to say about
this great nation of ours America yes
yes good good but what specifically
about America makes it so special
America well yes yes that goes without
saying but could you possibly go into
more detail America how many fingers am
i holding up America
what color is my hat America you can't
see anything else can you America and
this young man and I have clearly been
reading too deeply into your
uncontrollable mental illness America
well I still stand by this is the
greatest commercial of all time why okay
very calm and cool kid top that
America
America okay shut up well thanks for
watching my commercial special everybody
I hope you enjoyed it and hey whatever
did happen to that horny Wicked Witch
it's hot in here and I like you very
much
lover boy oh I mean the candles the
music the sexy dress what's going on
here don't you like me I'm your girl are
you doing this for
I want you what do you mean I want your
body don't I want to have sex with you
totally lost listen here you bizarre man
who was a picture of a spoon on his wall
for some reason I want your
[Music]
this is sexual harassment and I don't
need to take it
what does happened there is nothing
wrong with your computer do not attempt
to adjust your monitor we are
controlling the video if we wish to
annoy you will an obnoxious Papa band's
if we wish to infuriate you we will load
the video even slower so that all you
can see is the annoying circle if we
wish to confuse you we will satirize a
show that was popular in the 60s but
you'll still kind of get because you saw
it on that Simpsons Halloween special
for the next half hour sit quietly and
we will control all that you see and
hear you are about to experience the all
and mystery of nostalgic commercials
[Music]
they're back and they're ready to sell
you their shit nostalgic Saturday
morning commercials are practically a
lost art in that there's no more
Saturday morning cartoons to play them
with thanks non-stop kids floatation
media but nevertheless there was still a
strange otherworldly feel to the ads of
the 80s and 90s and even some more
recent ones too
so today we're gonna take a look at
their bright colorful sugar-coated brain
cell killing awesomeness in all its
glory
because commercials are reviewable -
what makes them memorable what makes
them laughable yeah what makes them
memorably laughable so seeing how they
call the first one after these messages
the second one we'll be right back the
third one explanation point then the
fourth one the fourth one this one I'm
calling the quickening
[Music]
now kids come yeah you all know this one
go ahead and this is the classic ad for
a toy I was pretty much just jump rope
for a disposable income best thing of
all on this bar Wow that is the best
thing of all remember when you had to
count look at the fucking terrible days
when you actually had to count not only
do I get to stay in just one place for
hours but I get to not think of numbers
while doing it this thing's the new
iPhone 6 as much as I love this ad have
you ever known anyone that was good at
it I mean fucking anyone I sure didn't
nobody I knew could ever get the hang of
this damn thing if they really want to
get it right they will very tight it
like this hey kids see the new toy in
town to get you more acquainted with the
ground it's TripIt jaded smashing faces
into asphalt trip it trip it to the toy
friend it's their fault
cuz perfect thing of all
phone numbers on the phone maybe you can
take those fastest to court super little
fuckers down to their short trip it
camping trip it's a lawsuit waiting to
happen
well it's still a catchy song that won't
be leaving anytime soon so there's the
strange period of time when the crash
test dummies which were originally PSA
is for a seatbelt safety got their own
toys made it was weird there was like an
evil dummy who wanted to stop their
crashing because that was a thing I
guess but in theory it was still kind of
cool because it was the only toy you
were expected to break even though every
commercial ended with the same line
don't be a dummy it's a little ironic
that you're learning about car safety by
being encouraged to crash a car this is
actually kind of sick yeah maybe that
one went through the windshield or that
one's fucking bleeding to death innocent
fun maybe I'm reading too deep into it I
mean after all it's not like there was a
torture chair to live out your sadistic
fantasies question Bank thought
Cristobal's holy shit
blam what does any of this have to do
with car safety okay
there's playful violence and then
there's saw this is all waters that
you're it really pick up beating
whatever fucked up part of our brains
like this it was a hit for a while even
if we should probably be concerned why
don't you be a dummy about or I'll kill
you
[Music]
I'm the melting ass animatronics from
Ninja Turtles three God how did they go
from Jim Henson puppetry to a dead-eyed
corpse with fishing line pulled lips
like mr. ed in football TV tossing Leo's
making sure the foot aren't having a
ball actually the funny thing is you can
tell this is one day we're running out
of ideas for stuff to put the Ninja
Turtles on in the early 90s they were
literally on everything no I mean
fucking everything like lively things
back fat yogurt so it's pretty obvious
this is when we were getting to the
point where they had very few options
left friends are you in the market for a
new car
Mike's Cowabunga surf buggy welcome back
to the international turtle game I just
love the Old West it's kinda like saying
remember when Batman took a baseball or
Wonder Woman took up bowling okay those
were actually real things but still
feels wrong it's crazy clouded by leader
in the turtle tribe bad deed Oh busting
my tits rap - magnificent hey there
but wait there's more uh uh there's
Ninja Turtles accounting ninja turtle
Tollbooth operator and last but not
least pregnant Ninja Turtles like
preggers Bunga things weren't going too
well okay we swear it's all part of the
original source material practically
nothing has changed it's not just an
attempt to have you buy it as a gift or
somebody's just boosting turtles just
what I've always wanted
[Music]
enjoy our fuse all yours for no money
down no installments you just pay for it
[Music]
we're out of ideas oh my god this may be
the greatest bumper for anything ever
okay so you're about to watch something
on HBO what do you usually see before it
starts fucking riveting you want to see
what they had back in the 80s
[Music]
but whimsical whimsy of wonderment is
this
[Music]
by God it feels like I'm flying over a
model of micromachines butts don't like
the music just keeps getting bigger and
bigger what's magical realm are we being
transported to you
[Music]
yes yes
Oh nowhere else will you find it genius
entertainment mixed in with pointless
moonshots
wait a minute could there be something
even more match cooling Bo
[Music]
[Applause]
fucking amazing I mean fucking amazing
what would you rather watch before it's
seeing anything
this we're incredible I guess or flying
like fucking Peter Pan to a Godzilla
model of wonder HBO you gotta bring this
back I don't care if you have to throw
in Tyrion Lannister or something just
for God's sakes bring this back even if
the movie are showing his goddamn
jack-and-jill it'll be a little bit
better with it
[Music]
yeah
I don't think that's how that works
was this like the missing line that
Rocky's coach used to say yeah gotta
drink water and crap me yummy want me
delicious chocolate listen girls and
wigs I just think you're kind of giving
kids the wrong idea I mean what if a
parent is like Oh somebody needs their
diaper change
yeah yeah no just just no just no I'm
Polly Pocket wanna see what's new Polly
Pocket wasn't this ingenious it's a tiny
girl who lives in the world that's also
a compact good Jesus that's like the
ultimate combination of girl toys
it's dolls doll houses and makeup all
rolled into one
it's the ultimate trifecta you'll be
vomiting for a week
nothing really wrong with these now that
I'm looking back at them growing up but
being a boy back then of course hated
watching these commercials I mean
they're just so girly
what they even do you open up this
little world walk through it and then
close it up to carry it around for
friggin it now boys we of course had a
lot better like payback Spidey man hell
yeah this was completely different and
so much better you open up this little
world walk through it and then close it
up to carry it around okay million times
more advanced that poly pissy pockets
just look at how into what this kid is
getting it's a little fucking psycho
watch bring watch out for that first
step it's not over - max get fried his
fate is in your hands that butterfly
whose wings I was going to pull off it's
so separately muddy max figure included
from Mattel what hell that wasn't the
end of it we had other super masculine
toys back then like
hell yeah here we go oh well if it's
just a dolphin I don't know creepy
crawlers yes before everything was after
everything was super but they meant
totally different things and don't you
forget and now you can make your own
wide-open power rangers cool to be fair
they look less like Power Rangers and
more like skinless human beings who got
wideout spilled on them but he captured
their non existent personalities pretty
good yeah now that's how you do a boy's
toy there isn't any girl's toy out there
that's even remotely close well our
version was better we couldn't eat ours
and live you know we came to think boys
toys were just girls toys painted a
different color and given less options
I feel so Center comes with everything
you see oh yeah can't forget this one
around the holidays a little snowman
comes in and gets warmed up to a bowl of
Campbell's soup only to reveal it was
actually a little boy the whole time
nothing melts away the cold like a
delicious bowl of Campbell's soup ok
concept and all but my biggest question
is look look there kid outside so long
that he would become a snowman that's
just horrible parenting in any other
world I don't think those will fly over
so smoothly
alright kiddo I think that's enough
playing outside time to come up in
[Music]
need a little help there okay oh you
were having a lot of fun out there
weren't you indeed but now it's time to
stop playing with your toys so all right
god I got I got Oh somebody's growing up
okay well why don't I make you a bowl of
your favorite Campbell's soup I'll take
that yes there you go honey a bowl of
your favorite Oh Craigs
[Music]
well it's still classic in many people's
eyes and I think it's still gonna be for
quite a while longer
just don't try it home
[Music]
those are good at all but every once in
a while you come across a commercial
that's so ridiculous and so stupid you
swear to not even try like this one
I was just lazy here you go everyone's
seen this classic before of course it
was always sunny D which is good it's
seeing how the mother always buys a
fucking wad ton of them
how many varying sizes of that shit do
you need we got soda Oh J purple stuff
two kinds of Sunny D oh hey the weird
thing about it is not that in every
commercial they always pick the Sunny D
that's kind of a no-brainer the weird
thing is that in every single commercial
they push aside the exact same drinks in
precisely the exact same order got soda
OJ Flint some soda okay purple stuff we
got soda OJ purple stuff okay soda Oh J
purple stuff we got sometimes Oh James
purple stuff we got Oh J : some purple
stuff how can so many homes have the
exact same thing and so many kids
dismiss them in the exact same lineup
soda OJ purple stuff maybe it's like a
cold like if we hear it enough times
we'll figure out it was the missing
combination - like that Stargate or
something soda
Oh J purple stuff and the missing piece
not funny tonight take us to the world
where the he-she from The Crying Game
will consume us all I don't know what
religious ritual you started SunnyD but
you need a little bit more variety do
none of these families drink milk
it's Sunny Delight the good stuff kids
go for I want that powerful style for
whatever reason the most intensed we
commercials in the late 80s and early
90s were laser tag guns it's like
they're in their own little epic sci-fi
movie like this one for example called
laser tag rocky
[Music]
that mom man let's go
we're late for our team the Owen Wilson
whiners already like this hole
Jesus Christ weirdo with this laser
tagging plane
[Music]
that's right once white Grace Jones has
called it there's no going back
what the hell was that I just got that
joke you told me ten minutes ago oh so
oh and Wicky are the last ones left this
is far too epic slow-mo that bitch so we
can enjoy it as long as possible
laser tag it's hotter than ever by God
that was incredible in an action that
had suspense and at ha and rookie laser
tag rocky was literally laser tag rocky
who can compare with that actually
believe it or not this one possibly
could this was an ad for laser pro 9000
today three kids and of course by kids
we naturally mean thirty year olds going
through some quarter life crisis wait a
minute
so there's two commercials going on here
there's actually a product placement the
product placement you looking for
something cold and the rest of the
commercial isn't tied to coke in any way
it's not like cold prisons laser pro
9000 it's just kind of a strained out of
nowhere bit of Maine dropping which is
ironic seeing how they didn't exactly
say the name very well Oh Coco Co I
always talk like I'm on a trampoline we
will fight for our six pack of
artificial flavors and freedom
so I'm not gonna lie I'm just assuming
this future takes place in the same one
that crossfire does a future focused on
the revolution of a plastic triggered
uprising it's gonna change the world
[Music]
game of the night laser throw 9000 yeah
they made no sense but for whatever
reason these laser tag commercials were
fuckin awesome laser pro 9000 each sold
separately of the loop we're not a sound
effect we're a company what douche I'm
sorry I know that's unbelievably
immature but this is coming from a time
period when women's commercials didn't
talk about women's things they always
use kind of this code word known as
fresh do you feel you know not so fresh
sometimes I just don't feel fresh my
best friend told me it's a real fresh
feeling fresh is a gentle breeze it's
natural to want to feel fresh but then
every once in a while you just get a
commercial that jumps straight to the
point like why do you can't buy any dish
more effective no more vinegar and water
dishes for me but when it comes to the
douche they use moved
sure that's why I douche I'm psycho the
next one up to child who stable this
some receive the most convenient
disposable douche you can buy hey
remember those commercials you swear
were from the 70s but were embarrassed
to find out they were made in your
decade mentos was a candy that seemed to
solve every stupid problem with an even
stupider answer but because the jackass
had mentos in his hands that apparently
made everything okay
I suppose it work seeing how everyone
remembers these ads but I just never got
how Mentos was the world piece of any
situation
[Music]
Mentos Manto's fuck me everything's
great
why is this the answer to all of life's
problems
[Music]
fresco battery life
nothing get to use a and sustain cool
with mentos precious
[Music]
and mentos the freshmaker what does it
matter you'll still be humming it and
that's what counts by getting away
scot-free with small crying that doesn't
hurt you
Mentos disrupt the system hey the
greatest family friendly system ever god
I remember when they used to make it
look like they could make your house Sol
or it could blast you out of your seat
or it could open up a world of
imagination you never thought possible
god I adored those whimsical commercials
so go ahead show us what's in store for
this one
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a dog why are you so scary now
[Music]
are you stealing my soul or I want you
good lord
we were really on this dictatorship test
don't be a kick for a while weren't we
what's this one selling there are places
where imagination is an outlaw where
freedom is feared where cookie boredom
rules and there are those who fight back
what there's someone who is brave enough
to stand up to cookie boredom don't you
know what your risky cookie Hitler
watches everything
yes they even had cookies back then and
as someone who tried a box with him once
and I'm still seeing the doctor valid
even to this day you can imagine they
weren't very good but like I said before
we were so obsessed with Ninja Turtles
that literally all we needed was that
first note of the theme song in order to
get us horned it was pathetic but
literally every kid watching this said
this looks pretty stupid and lame take
my money you play that one note we buy
the stuff we know how it works
nevertheless I think everybody has to
admit this is still a great commercial
for fighting off became a franchise that
was me Leslie everywhere oh my god guy
comes down back man em were threatening
graphics than this I should have done
that line of code before playing this
I'm just gonna look at a pop-up book for
a minute Jesus maybe the people in wolf
of wallstreet weren't even doing drugs
maybe they were just doing the Star Wars
Atari game the whole time I worked my
way from place to place I've got
everything I need right here with me
Star Wars it's that good
[Music]
more big adventures of honeycomb kid ah
honeycomb the only successful cereal
that clearly had no idea how to market
itself program year 3000 right wanted
lead on we're gonna go search for an
identity I'm thinking Indiana Jones Star
Wars Battletoads and I guess a little
Star Wars again the other guy really
seem to like it commercial guys cleave
travursel open your mouth and let
paedophilia jones do the rest of the
work
can't beat the big taste of honeycomb
cereal well it does wash out the big
taste of something else big adventure in
every bite especially when the lights
are off and it's probably best if you
don't bite a message from concerned
children's advertisers oh think out
another Canadian commercial they'll calm
us down from all this open your mouth
and close your eyes controversy why do
you think your mommy or daddy are always
telling you don't put that in your mouth
dammit Canada don't you put it in your
mouth in your mouth don't you spit in
your face though it might look good to
you and Michael good to eat you really
you were looking for a word to rhyme
with sick and that's the best one you
could come up with in this scenario in
your mouth do they have to look so
possessed while singing it - it just
doesn't add to the overall feel of the
experience
[Applause]
[Music]
just play it you all know what's coming
it's a rape whistle
Canada I make fun of you with this
because you have nothing else to make
fun of always ask someone you love
before you put anything in your mouth
except if that something your mouth is
the person that you love thank you for
watching my commercial special just
don't feel fresh hello I'm the Nostalgia
crank you know the rest if you're like
me you're excited that we get to review
commercials again who Keebler out
oh the nostalgia oh the memories oh the
mass marketing manipulation you can't
wait for him neither can i seeing how we
called the other episodes after these
messages
we'll be right back explanation point
the fourth one and the quickening this
one I'm in titling a Z let's just get to
it
Kershaw
hey kids remember what chucky cheese may
show biz pizza disappear under
mysterious circumstances well this is
how they used to advertise on TV the
most advanced video game you can play is
awaiting your discovery at Showbiz Pizza
place actually maybe the reason they ran
out of business is because they put fog
machines on top of their video games for
some reason it also doesn't help that
each game was given one giant dark room
to itself it supposed cost-effective as
Willy Wonka shrinking down his giant
chocolate bars who gives a shit he's
playing Dragon's Lair the most gorgeous
robbery of your money ever so many
quarters to this thing cuz we had to
keep reminding ourselves we weren't
watching a movie oh I hope Dirk's
reunited with his Russian Mouse family I
mean playing a game why didn't this ever
become a movie when that made sense
would you want it explain where that
flashing yellow light came from or the
Dragons ability to learn bubble trapping
technology or how Daphne major testicles
drop so fast why didn't I ever make this
a movie without Bluth and his people
what is it flashing yellow light he's
trying to tell me something
[Music]
why was i following a yellow light
a simple commercial but simply a tease
what's not to like about it brand new
at Showbiz Pizza place you can have lots
of high-tech fun with Tigers stock boy
tape recorder ah the only good thing to
come out of home alone too
that's I haven't even gay or Tim Curry
have a lovely day the whole movie
practically served as an advertisement
for this thing yeah that's what a voice
app used to look like kids in fact
that's practically what cell phones used
to look like to the commercial just
shows a boy playing pranks on his sister
that's cute and all but you got a
question a little bit of the
plausibility like the voice speed
control hi kids were home early what
creepy as parents sounds like that is
there a kid and some friends out there
who really has a father who's like hi
kids I'm about to go slaughter puppies
you stay here and go to bed by 11:00 or
I'll eat your heart
[Music]
I think I need to be potty trained again
data technology today but canticle back
then with a funny if not disturbing add
to go along with it
Tigers top boy tape recorder comes with
audio cassette as recommended by Peter
McAllister full full-price lady who
bathes like that my ass you're making a
bigger mess than a dog who just walked
through a thunderstorm this asshole
who's he on a trampoline I'm only two
feet tall don't judge me please this
turns a relatively relaxing part of your
day into a seizure inducing physical
strain they'll cause you more spasms as
sponge in an electric chair
[Music]
what this dude he just wants to take a
nice quick relaxing shower what the hell
does he get
I knew I shouldn't have taken crystal
meth in the morning
speaking of people clearly on drugs my
heroes ybarra so by me counseling I
don't know why they have to make getting
clean look like an orgasmic in waterpark
but I guess it worked because they're
still talking about it today pretty
silly but it's a camping kind of silly
kind of hard not to still get a giggle
[Music]
here's an old favorite
it's a coach trying to get his team
excited to win the big game but an organ
dicing of pasta gets them hyped up for
SpaghettiOs instead because yeah I'd get
a lot more excited for that than winning
a freaking sport
what the hell are they even playing it's
a unisex sport with no uniforms and a
game plan that looks more like a map to
bury treasure no wonder they're
distracted by melted gnocchi they don't
even know what to play tomorrow
wait wait where he goes again don't you
hate it when he motivates us for a
miscellaneous sport that we don't like
but we signed up for anyway yeah you got
it right kids sports are dumb
SpaghettiOs are awesome but just like
that controversial Super Bowl last year
the game has been cancelled because both
teams want to eat SpaghettiOs a weird ad
for a gross product but one they'll
still stay fresh in our memories well
that was just said okay I'm just gonna
let you figure things out little girl
there's no rush just you might watch
check out some of these cartoons okay
you just kissed her nipple I'm okay with
being curious but sleeping in pink
potato sacks it's not consent oh look
she sleeps the same way zestfully clean
people bathe I guess you'd want to move
around too if you slept in a nightgown
that even the Duggars would call too
conservative
bedtime Barbie doll has a soft body okay
I don't want to force any gender
stereotypes or anything like that but
what if this was a boys commercial like
the exact same lines and everything just
you switched out the genders to male
would we really look at this the exact
same way Barbie I can sleep with mm-hmm
snuggle tonight
bedtime Barbie I'll hold you tight
bedtime Barbie her body side let's get
ready for bed
snuggle tonight bedtime Barbie I'll hold
you tight bedtime Barbie bedtime Barbie
doll has a soft body now with an adult
version for dead okay that part I ended
up but you get the idea what can one say
but naivete thy name is bedtime Barbie
[Music]
Oh
McDonald's is one of the kings of
children's marketing using the only
clown who's a surprisingly slower killer
than Pennywise it's all about
these ads always have brilliant slogans
and catchphrases that would change up
every year or two but sometimes they
were said so fast that you'd swear they
sound a little bit like something else
like listen to this and tell me if one
of these words sounds just the tiniest
bit like something else this might be
healthy did McDonald's at Caligula's
home but not on Saturday mornings
[Music]
this is way too unsettling I gotta find
something more pure and innocent
hi I'm shared the subway guy I'm losing
weight deliciously with the aid of aims
aids helps put me in control aids may
taste like a candy but aids contains one
of the most effective appetite
suppressants you can buy hey let me lose
the weight and has nothing in it that
could make me nervous
I think a lot of people would disagree
with you on that question why take diet
pills when you can enjoy aids I can
safely say there are some reasons AIDS
helps you curb your appetite you eat
less because you want less so you lose
weight naturally no few other side
effects seeds helps you stay the way you
want to be why not try aids okay dude
this came out in the mid 80s where none
of you reading a paper so why don't you
let aids help you lose weight
let the aids plan teach you how to take
off weight and help keep it off trying
peanut butter aids peanut butter aids
excuse me your ignorance has caused me
to retreat into
the uncomfortable corner lose weight
deliciously with the aid of AIDS now
comes with sweaty collar to tug at Wow
giant peanut butter AIDS okay
we gotta get the bad taste of that
commercial out of our heads so let's
travel all the way to Japan for one of
the greatest ads of all time it's for
the Sega savvy and to emphasize how
intense it was they created Sega toss
Sun shadow the most aggressive
spokesperson ever it didn't matter what
you were doing if you were off to play
baseball he beat the shit out of you and
say place at her and instead going out
dancing tonight fuck that noise you're
playing Saturn now the sousaphone
Hey look it's Santa oh shit it's a
guitar first up fling Sega goddammit
when he wasn't pounding the console into
you both figuratively and literally he
was winning soccer games beating skaters
with no skates killing zombies falling
in love and training to his kick-ass
theme song
[Applause]
[Music]
as hot dogs
this guy is amazing it's like Chuck
Norris fully realized you know like if
you have Chuck Norris I took out the
homophobe stuff he'd have Sega top
he's like a myth they talked about in
story if that myth had a physical
forming country he was one of the most
phenomenal things to ever hit television
sadly though every myth has to die yep
they actually killed off Saget ah in the
only way Sega too could die stopping a
nuclear warhead from destroying Sega by
jumping off a building propelling it
back with his own feet and launching it
into space it was pretty emotional
[Music]
Sega Python sure Jimmy tattoo Lulu we
will never forget you Sega top will
ironically forget the Sega Saturn it's
not round anymore but you always live on
he's one of the most awesome series of
commercials ever and I proudly support a
beating of me if it means seeing more of
his incredible
[Music]
one of the year's most enchanting
stories is about to bloom Oh God you
ever look at an ad for a movie and say
shit I'm gonna have to look at this for
a few months no Don Bluth the director
of an American tale but director who
gave us some of the greatest anime
movies of all time says you know what
maybe Barney was onto something
a troll in Central Park now you too can
enjoy the Wonder and enchantment of a
friendship that grows and blossoms yeah
I'm just waiting for dirt that daring to
slice his head off or the t-rex from
land before time to devour him when the
owl from secret of NIMH to peck his
little face out don bluth op this da
Bluth film and I know what you're
thinking aren't I being a little too
hard on an animation legend well if he
has a problem with that he can tell me
himself Don Bluth
oh my god I am the biggest look at me
right now super name is one of my
favorite all-time movies the holy shit
americantale but he's just like right
there what the fucking black wait before
time oh my god before Joyce Lucas was a
swear word sounds like the most
unbelievable thing me like I was a
kick-ass movie about dinosaurs you are
amazing now what are you doing right now
just waiting I want to see what you're
gonna do
what oh I see because I made fun of some
of your working the patch or giving me
the silent treatment huh okay I'm not
gonna be intimidated by film giant like
you you can't give me the side treatment
I can give you the exact same thing back
knock-knock oh come on it's the law you
have to say who's there knock knock
who's there you go you go who you go
bye-bye these buttons has to work what's
this one do it's the most tediously
advertise hand garments until frozen now
you can be tough by looking like a mix
between a NASCAR driver and Dexter's ma
look you even pretend you're the Power
Rangers with this stock footage just
like the real actors pretend they're the
Power Rangers with stock footage
actually the flames thing about this
commercial isn't even the gloves it's
the alarm you're supposed to put outside
your door oh yeah if you got bullies at
your school that serda scare him away
look at that he hears the sound and he
immediately goes into a seizure I think
most of us know what would really happen
in this situation oh your money hey as
long as they don't play let it go I'm
totally okay with these things existing
Power Rangers watch TV projector lamp
and room defender sold separately from
happiness Express now you'll tell me why
Superman peanut butter tastes so great
slow day for evil Alex never so fresh
roasted so creamy so yummy that secret
would be mine all mine
I needed to make my ultimate weapon
peanut butter aids the kids save
Superman and supposedly put Luther away
in jail but no is it me or just
look more like Rapunzel's tower why do
they lock him up in the same place
Bowser holds Princess Peach also
Superman was ready to die to keep the
recipe of his peanut butter safe
that's some pretty jacked up priorities
there you know Superman it is only
peanut butter never if you only give me
the recipe never have you ever seen
kryptonite kill a man your insights get
eaten out eyes burst through your
sockets and blood comes out your ears
and nose but you're gonna go through all
of that just for your damn peanut butter
yes you know I'm starting to wonder
which one of us is the true crazy one
here that's like these oh no Chuck this
super butter isn't still around
just wait Superman I'll find out
Superman peanut butter its strength is
it's great taste and the fact that
apparently makes you invisible what what
the hell doesn't a doubt I insist on a
cereal but offers nutritional frosting
yeah remember these these were the
frosted mini-wheats commercials that
advertise to both adults and kids as
adults and kids
I love the crunchy bleep taste of
Kellogg's many weeks but the frosting
site agrees with the little kid in me
the adults would always talk about the
healthy aspects of the cereal while the
kids always talked about the
sugar-coated part of it the proper shell
is low in facts and taste what about
Dave the only problem is if any adult
really could communicate with himself
years later it probably wouldn't be as
chipper as they were letting on I am a
very proper adult so I always eat it's
filled with whole-grain wheat and is so
nutritious for inside of course if the
younger me knew this creeping off the
sugar side would have prevented it from
being a diabetic he probably won't have
eaten it wait what
oh yes and don't even get me started on
your colon that kids have really jacked
up do you I don't want to know this
neither did I but you go through it
along with the next wife a divorce that
cost you most of your earnings
don't forget child support to look after
little brats like you I hope raised I
think I hear my mom golly your mom's
dead couldn't afford to pay all the
medical bills Hector fine you all this
sugar frosted mini-wheats for your damn
loudmouth do yourself a favor and never
grow up never fall in love never get
attached to anybody in your life you
hear me it's not right it's not to like
change your life before Bob Boston
mini-wheats is part of this complete
breakfast you knew this was coming
someday still a cute idea
even if reality can get the best of it I
know it goes on light rare the sweet
stuff
hey little buddy want a ride I was in
college when Pokemon came out so I was
not the right age for it and if you're a
little kid and grew up with it great I'm
glad to have fun but for all the adults
who had to endure this this was a pain
in the ass to put up with it was
everywhere it was like every boyband
except the obnoxious music was replaced
with pika pika pika we didn't know what
it was about and we didn't care we just
knew it was annoying
so friggin annoying so pardon me if I'm
not very excited to watch another
commercial on it
[Music]
I'll be right back wait
my god is it true are they finally gonna
die
just squats them kill them all turn them
into pokeyman pokeyman
[Music]
my god that was beautiful I don't know
who you are fisheye lens fat man but you
are my new personal hero where can you
catch all 150 Pokemon on your Gameboy
that's where Bob bullshit a fucking cop
out how do you get a gameboy from a box
you know what strip with a color of
emotional denial I will rewrite this
ending in my head the way I walk it's
both where can you catch all 150 Pokemon
Oh happy thoughts
a nice dark idea even if it does need to
go to happy near the end you're looking
at the next breakthrough for the Super
Nintendo Entertainment System ah yes the
super scope the ROVs the robot of the
Super Nintendo okay so you're a Nintendo
kid and you have a ton of fun blasting
things with your blaster what do you
want that's even more advanced than that
well gee uh how about a shotgun or a
machine gun or bazooka you ready okay in
hindsight it does sound kind of cool I
mean bazookas make big explosions and
we're all sick fog so we like that but
with those other guns you could be
mobile you can move around you can
pretend you're an action hero who
pretends to have a bazooka what little
kid is like hey you want to go play cops
and robbers
I much rather play gigantic piece of
plastic I place on my arm immediately
making it sore and sitting still looking
for a little eyepiece I'm gonna hear
about you in the news Anna Sui it was so
boring even to look at that they had to
line up a bunch of them in a row
tricking you into thinking it was more
cool than it really was
yeah you know the one thing they're not
doing firing them at the friggin stream
because it's goddamn boring oh wait do
it once here we go now back to all the
exciting things you will never do with
it you might want to consider some basic
training it's designer I know it's like
a collector's item and it has a special
place in people's hearts but there's a
reason it never caught on and it's yours
for under $60 Christ that sounds like
too much even today it was a lot more
bag than give these ads credit for
trying to make it look good that's
another one of those accessories that
just never got the momentum Indies super
scope 6 only for Super Nintendo
it's not virtual boy but it's close
here's a little PSA from Canada nah no
I've learned my lesson Canada is fucked
up they may look all cute and innocent
but then there's nicking in rape
whistles and putting dicks in your mouth
and God knows what else
well I'm not falling for it this time
and the sous-chef here with any luck I
should be head chef by next year oh well
that sounds kind of nice
I've got this amazing fiance oh well
that sounds sweet a nice couple finally
found love I won't be marrying this
weekend
Oh what you had to change the date or
something that's always so hard when
that happens cuz I'm about to be in a
terrible accident huh
I really I should have cleaned up the
grease over there and they should never
put the deep fryer so yes visiting scary
you're scary please turn it up put it on
your flag you're scaring we're keeping
Michael J Fox you keep whatever the hell
we gave you which is probably nothing
push a sack
oh yeah oh if you're too young to
remember this then you need an education
the idea of having a wrestler advertise
beef jerky sounds a standard as anything
but when that wrestler is Randy Savage
and he's given one hell of an extreme
campaign it turned out to be one of the
coolest ads ever
yeah let's face it when a room starts
shaking its shit starts blowing up this
is the person you want to see causing it
Romeo Romeo wherefore art thou Romeo
oh damn it was Slim Jim
there has never been a more pleasing
image to come out of a puff of smoke
he's like the cooling man if he slipped
you ecstasy you just never wanted this
guy to leave other words you can take it
down well snap into it yeah but do it
Slim Jim
look at this it's a room full of lamps
I'm getting hard just thinking of Randy
Savage busting in here
oh my god is there a way to mate with
slim jims
don't answer that internet journalist
Blythe he had so much testosterone even
seeing the letter T seems super
aggressive statement these are some of
the coolest ads ever and so much of it
came from the macho man himself if you
haven't come across any of these yet
then definitely go check them out yeah
beef curry of spice new excitement step
into a slim jim girls want to talk in
the phone with a toddler of course you
haven't
cuz that be goddamn insane but this
exists for some reason barking we're
right what are the chances of finding
another girl who likes shopping we're
like soul mates two-year-old who seems
uncomfortably well-spoken
[Music]
does she cuz it sounds like mostly
useless shit to me it's like they're
trying to combine traditional girl stuff
to a point where it makes no sense like
hey you like horses and dresses here's a
dress made on horses you like babies and
cooking here's how to cook babies you're
like dancing at tea parties but we Pride
and Prejudice it's an engaging read of
challenging social class why did these
things come together I don't know it
doesn't seem to still be around so I
guess it didn't work some combinations
are clever this one is just well you
could promote dragons there by
supporting our crowdfunding campaign you
mean you are making a Dragon's Lair
movie yeah actually we ironically have
never done a commercial in a commercial
special before but wait so you're
telling me that if you get this funded
we would have gotten Don Bluth the dumb
Bluth one of the animation gods to
return to animation but if you're gonna
do it you have to do it the right way
right way what what's the right way the
most advanced video game you can play is
a wedding your discovery
[Music]
hey wanna see this on the big screen
will make dragon boy or a movie dragon
slayer you need that awesome arcade game
we were just playing no talking while
I'm talking yeah ready for some
excitement
the viral movie
[Music]
lady there's only room for one screaming
psychopath around
[Applause]
Oh
the dragon's lair a movie or dump loop
will give you the dip steer
yeah nostalgia critic reviewing
commercials like you give a shit oh
[Music]
what's the Green Goblin up to now
oh no he's forcing spider-man to play
his own Atari game actually that is kind
of whoa this isn't enjoyably goofy
commercial but what really sells it is
the guy playing the Goblin
I think his dentist put meth in his
laughing gasps I love this guy he can't
leave the frame without going nuts stop
presenting show some dignity when you're
in that costume
what's he even saying here he's so
excited I can't make it out okay I've
watched this over a hundred times I've
studied it
I've analyzed every possibility I still
don't know what the hell he's saying
here are my closest guesses
we laugh at this but honestly it's not
too far off from what some of the movies
have if Goblin and spider-man can relax
on a roof in those ridiculous outfits
playing an Atari game isn't too far off
I could crush you like a bug right now
but let's play video games instead
seriously you told her yeah hunch yeah I
thought was a good pick-up line for some
reason I've got to be less awkward than
how I cut a Thanksgiving turkey or
crawling the floor to a chair with a
Spencer's mask on it yeah let's hope
nothing is ridiculous is in our near
future outside of a song and dance
number how couldn't can I say but web
slinging fun never looks so pixelated
vitamin-a video game from Parker
Brothers no one to beat whoa stand back
the world's most exciting toys are here
this is the Federal Express Air Cargo
playset yeah I remember how jealous I
was of the kids that had Federal Express
playsets
here I was watching the side of my
painted house dried I had no idea
there's something even more boring the
door is opened and a real conveyor
system inside the plane moves the
containers into the cargo bay hey slow
down something so much excitement we
could take now Federal Express takes off
again with cargo for Phoenix I have
enough intensity with my pet rock thank
you very much
they're put in containers loaded on
trailers and taken to the plane did that
really deserve a WoW I could barely
muster in a band delivers packages to
the airport I prepared for a lifetime of
disappointment New York Miami yeah this
commercials pretty much as boring as it
sounds come on guys get the micro
machine man working for you would you
utilize him somehow this is supporting
my skin is actually turning into
cardboard the Federal Express air cargo
playset comes with everything you see
here from playschool FedEx putting
return to sender on your kids
imagination
think we'll beat that tonight sure we
will after this complete breakfast
including my frosted flakes ah Tony the
Tiger you represent everything youthful
and strong with the voice of an 80 year
old though Tony's of course still around
there was a very distinct formula that
was used in the 80s and 90s ads you see
though it starts with Tony befriending
some random kid and some random sport
who's always being made fun of boys time
to tie our sweaters around our chests
and throw Cadillacs at puppies I hope
your service good you guys never we
don't wanna hear what's wrong with these
dipshits you're making fun of a kid that
has a killer predator on his side this
is not gonna end well they have good
yarn what are you gonna do SiC your
giant animated tiger on me but of course
it's the great taste of frosted flakes
that brings out their inner tiger and
transforms them into a sports star very
good
you see some false advertising in that
some me protein bars vegetables these
are things that can make you a better
athlete
sugar-frosted newspaper cannot nobody
says you know what make people who eat
Wheaties even stronger candy flavoring
there's even chocolate covered versions
with marshmallows how is any of this
supposed to make you a sports star if
they really want to be honest with the
ads they'd be like hey loser static your
parents died in a car crash oh those
guys that's what you think what you need
is a helping of my Tuffy wings
it brings out the toughness in you see
figure T good toffee flakes good wait
what yeah there's no weed in this we
just scrape off the top of sugar cubes
and Dan Brown's incredibly unhealthy
[Music]
board give me a guest tiger you make
some weird green
because you know what's cool baby I feel
dizzy and weak that's just the diabetes
set again what you need is an excellent
yes dog your breakfast right with what
most people call dessert when you have a
taste of Tuffy's toffee blanks it brings
out the tops we miss advertised well
it's still fun and Tony such a great
mascot it's hard not to get sucked into
all the sports testing propaganda kids
gathered round for nobody sighing hey
hey stand back son of a bitch thinks he
can take on Simon oh girl I think that
jacket just put you through early
puberty I will smell Johnny's jacket all
through the night
smells like SpaghettiOs and victory I
want to blow away this easily impressed
group of fourth-graders
Simon is the challenge you've been
waiting for if you take on the challenge
of pushing beeping buttons you get the
great reward of the beeping without you
pushing up it takes coordination of hand
and mind just pranking I love how
politely he thanks the machine before he
soaks up the victory I want to thank you
for a challenging game it really did
well to enhance my reflexes
these kids it's just Simon guys I mean
what do you think this is crossfire you
may be cool Simon but you're not
crossfire being played by dante basco
dressed as firebender Zuko cool chick
had the lucky gives when the girl puts
the jacket on him he's just like girl
you my bitch now
Simon Says I own your ass it ain't
crossfire but as game commercials go
it's a close second
Simon is waiting for you from Milton
Bradley you my bitch now we all know
McDonald's has Rama Macdonald before a
while
Burger King hit the Burger King kids
club lasted for a good chunk of time
until they realize the 90s wanted to die
and this was the last remaining threader
I mean look at them
they're drenched in the 90s it even has
all the 90s token characters the token
geeky kid the token Hispanic kid the
token black kid the token wheelchair kid
and woo - token girls are ready truth be
told it was kind of neat to have such a
wide variety but they never really had
any characteristics like the McDonald's
commercials
Ronald was confident ly goofy grimace
was a doofus Hamburglar was a
troublemaker what are these kids at
story um they kidnap kids through black
magic
this'll take you away from your ethical
obligations they take pictures of boys
bathing okay you and this girl neither
talking to turn away people they don't
like your turning away dinosaurs what's
wrong with you your coolness would have
gone up a million percent if you had a
t-rex as a member for crew that's trying
to be so open and accepting you sure say
no do a lot of people happy not scream
bagpipe players they can go to hell no
wonder your characters never sold that
great hey guys want to go to the toy
store Burger King may toys boring I
don't know they'll ever get a reaction
from us again a valiant attempt but they
don't even mention their names in the
commercials
oh we're gonna see em Eze is the black
kid the Hispanic kid and Cyclops
what do they call you wheels actually
yes
awkward stupidest thing I've ever heard
[Music]
always a classic jingle for a classic
product but while we all remember how to
dunk it eat an Oreo cookie what is up
with these kids reaction to them I swear
you could freeze any of these and it
looks like the Oreos are opening up the
Dark Dimension from Doctor Strange
look even transform this kid into a
young Bill Cosby which is probably gonna
be very bad in the future you got those
all over the place that takes on a whole
new meaning don't look directly into
this boy's eyes it'll send you directly
to hell
[Music]
they said it wasn't humanly possible
well here it is folks the first ever
Gameboy commercial and I'm not gonna lie
they may have overhyped it now you can
have all the power and excitement of
Nintendo right in the palm of your hand
really all the power and excitement of
Nintendo huh is that why in this
30-second commercial there is only one
second of gameplay in it I'm not even
kidding this is the only clip of game
footage they show but look giant robots
on Doctor Who sets like it and that's a
little awkward I'm sorry but seeing a
giant machine come out and hold a
calculator like a texting gourd doesn't
look especially intimidating the loser
has to watch the Keanu Reeves version
and it's games are interchangeable Plus
beaten boy comes with a beret just new
game Tetris which rages Tetris huh
there's many words to describe Tetris
but outrageous isn't usually one of them
so are Aegeus that only one second of it
can be shown to show the rest of it will
blow your mind to mine okay if you want
to do an ad truthfully you do it like
this now you can have all the power and
excitement of Nintendo right in the palm
of your hands and by all we mean
literally one color roughly four bits
and a variety of maybe five sound
effects really crappy robots from the
60s locked you could give it a game gear
which in hindsight was a million times
better but because ours was a tiny bit
smaller it bombed enjoy what your mom
will be playing on her phone in 20 years
wait does my existence rely on this I
totally did only from Nintendo before
that even if it is overhyped now go
playing with power every morning at this
time the dad puts one of those great
they go out for visitors - yep
who can forget leggo my eggo the
catchphrase nobody said because nobody
would ever fight for
leggo my eggo oh my go my go but in the
commercials everybody wanted one it
would go to crazy lengths to get it even
though they were clearly many left
behind I feel like these are some
extreme lengths to go to to get one of
them well they come in like packets of
812 you can come on guys time is ride
pretty and goes don't it probably the
most extreme is a kid that created an
invisibility suit with science you're
sinning against time in nature for an
eggo waffle the wound is not ready for
such technology or deliciousness it's
cute and all but these ideas were done
today I think they might have gone a
different direction
my dad always tries to get my egg a
waffle in the morning before I do
but with my black arts magic the
advantage is mine I do it cool I've
distilled mom you did it cuz I saw the
Sun now you see like up on a Dutch door
door and that's how it's done
oh no you don't 11 this waffle is mine
Eagle waffles is part of a complete
breakfast Lego might I'll shut up weird
but harmless enough
aigo knows how to focus on stranger
things and then that's weird ones like
this they either show you an advertise
make sure you nothing but plaque I never
got them tell me what you think
we are right so random shopping makes me
hungry level at bear yes many of you
know the Care Bears were a thing for a
while and that included toys I'm not
even sure I always got them like one was
for dress-up did girls like to dress up
bears was that a thing we're nudists I'm
proud but strangely enough the most
frightening thing is when they would
speak I know that doesn't sound like
anything but just listen to when they
talk someone talk to you Christ you
should take voice lessons from the girl
in the ring they also make cheap
novelties when you can't afford actual
presence no seriously what to get me my
goddamn leg is broken as well as ruining
birthdays yeah no wonder he has no
friends at this party is excited to get
a Care Bear stay there I'm gonna beat
you up after this review come to tender
heart fair I'm so proud give us no that
was not a good frame to freeze on this
is it to say even the toddler's figure
out quickly they're being gypped hey as
long as they don't talk and see yourself
lucky kid I guess they got the job done
but did they have to be so cutely freaky
and share your special feelings today
[Music]
when that states this character was kind
of cool he was called Mac tonight
also known as moon so purpose was to let
you know that McDonald's is open later
and dare we say a classy place to hang
out at night the answer is no you may
not dare to say that
look cool on the character was pretty
neat but I'm sorry this would never
convince anyone McDonald's is an upscale
place to be your just ain't gonna happen
mmm when these McNuggets are especially
chicken listed a griddle of the Mik
variety oh how frightfully witty why
isn't that Julius from Walmart never
mind me I'm just seeing if they still
have the McLobster yes yes that is I
guess it doesn't help that this moon guy
is also a little creepy just watch what
happens when you switch out the music
from this actual ad they used to play
[Music]
I will stab your heart with my chair
only I am Bruce Campbell can do that
still a cool character even if he is a
bit nightmare-inducing
Mac I'll make it back tonight
may be absolutely remarkable my
interactive poon where's yours why are
we talking about extraordinary new poo
are we having lunch with grandpa again
who interacts with your child and
computer that sounds very unsanitary
downloading take boots bunny anywhere
take poo fun anywhere I'd imagine get
arrested for something like that hello
yeah no I'm Way too childish to talk
about a children's commercial but let's
just say this isn't my number one
commercial but it's definitely my number
two PSA from when the Adam West Batman
show was still on let's see what 60s
Batman had to throw at us prick Batgirl
untie us before it's too late it's
already too late
I've worked for you a long time and I'm
paid less than Robin holy same job same
employer means equal pay for men and
women no time for jokes that girl
it's no joke it's the Federal Equal Pay
law holy act of Congress can we talk
about this later
will Batgirl save the dynamics you
well she got equal pay our division
Department of Labor okay where do I
start with this first of all Adam West
is really phoning it in
isn't he his life is on the line yet it
sounds like he's teaching a geometry
class quickback girl untie us before
it's too late and please tell me the
property for X second Batman is kind of
an asshole equal pay for men and women
no time for jokes Batgirl wow what a
douche I mean come on you're a vagina
alone Docs you like 20% even Robins like
come on you crazy Dame we gave you the
boat what else do you want
third superheroes get paid when did this
start our superheroes getting regular
wages do they have a union plus I don't
know what the paychecks are but the idea
of anyone getting paid less than Robin
is frigging hilarious fourth she's just
gonna let Batman die kids a ho must be
pissing themselves she's about to kill
their favorite hero and a young boy
batgirls gonna become everyone's most
hated characters as The Killing Joke
fifth even with the threat of killing
Batman women still are given equal pay
this was made back in the 60s and it's
still unequal we'd rather see one of our
favorite superheroes dive and give a few
more bucks to these weird pitted
creatures dude if that's not gonna do
anything I don't know what will sex well
it is well intentioned is this really
the best time for Batgirl to bring this
up couldn't I like sit down and discuss
a back and forth or a protest or I don't
know call your Congressman like you just
said I mean how awkward must things be
between Batman and Batgirl after this
situation
you know this reminds me of the time
when I was in a similar situation I
remember yeah you were gonna let me
explode if you didn't get equal pay no
you're talking about you know world
hunger is still a big issue no no no I'm
serious I'm actually thinking maybe we
should put your life on the line until
we get world hunger soft you know you'd
stay there and blow up I don't get my
PowerPoint presentations
[Music]
okay I'm still here though a
well-meaning message done in a
hilariously ridiculous way what else
could you say but holy acts of Congress
[Music]
here's another PSA from Canada oh no no
no before Canada you always tried to
make them look so friendly and nice but
then there's rape whistles and face
burnings and putting things in your
mouth well I'm ready for you this time
Canada do your worst it's nighttime in a
kitchen just like yours
all is quiet or is it that the North
American house hippo is found throughout
Canada in the eastern United States
House hippos are very timid creatures
and are rarely seen but they will defend
their territory of the vote they come
out at night to search for food water
and materials for their nests the
favorite foods of the house hippo are
chips
raisins and the crumbs from peanut
butter on toast for your cuteness cattle
where you go they build their nests in
bedroom closets using lost mittens dryer
lint and bits of string and then they
flamethrower your family don't smoke
oops suppose sleep about 16 hours a day
that looked really real but you knew it
couldn't be true didn't you that's why
it's good to think about what you're
watching on TV and ask questions it's
kind of like you just did the message
from concerned children's advertisers
well that was nice
downright adorable so let me get this
straight candidate you start off your
dark disturbing PSAs as cute and
innocent and start off your cute and
innocent PSAs as dark and disturbing
what are you Canada you're like a riddle
inside an enigma inside up please and
thank you
okay cool the house hippo don't believe
everything you see
fair enough a cute harmless even
educational PSA that's good for you
Canada I will not have nightmares
tonight okay we could Canada we good
thank you for that enlightening very
pleasant PSA on to the next one
okay so here's one from Britain called
electricity football oh cool I always
wonder what their version of electric
football was like oh it's that kind of
football that's fun I'm still curious to
see how kids play that I know Mike Tyson
that record don't walk you don't touch
anything not seeing any plugs boards
[Music]
they say stay out don't take a chance
with electricity stay up Oh trust me I
will you all like trick you kids like
bug zappers you can keep your terry
gilliam Oh finally a star purse
commercial okay something a little less
freaky you tried these new berries and
cream starburst pardon me what kind of
style best did you just say berries
everything what else you cream oh okay
commercial I'll bite where are you going
with this berries and cream berries and
cream I'm a little louder those berries
and cream give up just give up give up
on everything what are we doing is this
really what we're paying people to give
us now we're denying good writers such
wonderful paychecks so that
piece-of-shit writers can give us this
this was a gift that only the rare
exceptional talent could give us and we
said yes let's make this a hit let's
reward the asshole who came up with this
on his lunch break stoned off his ass
when he went in to pitch that's
commercial and they said Larry you're
stoned off your ass and Larry said yes I
am and they said well 11 million people
are stoned off their asses too cuz 11
million people watched it on YouTube and
not only that they shared it and came
back for more they said I'm not talented
enough to come up with something so
ingenious and you got more there are
remixes of this commercial there's other
variations of this commercial from
different angles completely different
mind you look there's
Virginie says this are those new berries
and cream stop everything it was trying
to accomplish is this what takes help is
this what if I want to sell those black
cows would I feel like you blacked out
blacked out I pooped a black out and
that would sound like a badge a piker
would black cow cheese stalks just don't
through the roof if i play that ad I say
no to you berries and cream
I say no I've taken a lot of stupidity
over the years but this lunacy madness
take I will not this commercial is awful
it's just stupid and awful
I'm sick of insanity being rewarded I'm
sick of laziness being counted as clever
I want something to make sense there's
good reason for my listening skin and
how my pores are so clean and clear I
eat little babies ice cream it keeps me
young
it keeps me light on my feet i spring
from activity to activity when you eat
little babies ice cream you'll wink and
nod with great enthusiasm ice cream is a
feeling okay okay I apologized that
version of me has expired he simply had
nothing more to give he tried he tried
very very hard to look inside himself to
find something anything that he could
offer but in the end you just took too
much from him world
he just took too much from him he will
be missed a moment of silence a view
me on the other hand this is the
freakiest thing I have ever seen this is
for something called little babies ice
cream it would scare the piss out of any
little babies watching it it's so
terrifying and I even convinced it's
made for little babies I think it's made
out of little babies don't believe me
watch it again and just take out the ice
cream part tell me if it makes a little
too much sense I eat little babies it
keeps me young
it keeps me light on my feet when you
eat little babies
you'll wink and nod this is a special
time little babies is a feeling little
baby's ice cream is people well if
there's anything I've learned from this
commercial special it's that fear sells
everything so without further ado I have
a black couch to sell and I know the
best way to do it creepy people with
pointy heads and chins and who kill you
in your sleep by the cows polio kid that
eat your souls with
Oh blah geez
I'm the Nostalgia Critic and pleasant
dreams
[Music]
yeah this one watches the nostalgic
fields it's the first commercial for
super smash brothers on the Tendo 64 now
it's a common plays idea to see your
favorite lovable characters beat the
shit out of each other
but back then seeing these cuddly cue
ball skip was pretty shocking when it
was followed by this suddenly it's
Joaquin Phoenix from gladiator looking
over an enchanted bloodbath Nintendo
what I like is before you realize it's
all going this direction it just looks
like Mario snapped at Yoshi did you have
a flashback to when he was a baby and
Yoshi failed to protect him
forgive asshole you're such a moron ten
points to whoever threw pikachu twice by
the way skipping if they were just gonna
fight is it like a Clockwork Orange
where Mario knew he was gonna jack them
up I was calm on the outside but
thinking all at the time so not what you
always see the general is saying what to
do and what not to do when Ivy did what
to do could you just give her venge by
dropping him off another cliff we know
the Yoshi species are like socks to you
ultra violent as hell but pretty funny
too this commercial hits hard in the
laughs only on Nintendo 64 hey kids want
to eat your bling seek help and then
seek a ring pop will you wear my ring
[Music]
it's a catchy jingle and a typical setup
but it is one of those few commercials
that have me constantly asking the
question what happened after I know I
know these are just playful scenarios to
set up jokes but what if they didn't
cutaway help the rest of these scenes
play out will you wear my ring seriously
where's the ring though well I you kept
a box behind your back saying will you
wear my ring you do not screw with a
girl when it comes to that well well I
got some tootsie rolls if you're
interested in any of the can turn it
around and wear it on the inside what
does that have to do okay what the hell
you told me there was a ring I thought I
was fighting the school bully I was
pissing myself with fear was all just a
pun for edible jewelry here's your Pop
[Music]
my wife is a toddler and tre is starring
Julie are you giving candy on your
walkway clothes
you better not chubby thighs
nevertheless it's a cute commercial for
a cute product believe it or not there
was a time when the funniest commercials
you could watch or milk commercials yeah
in the early 90s milk sales were down so
the California milk processor board
hired renowned advertising agency
goodbee silverstein and partners to make
milk well kind of cool but how do you do
that it's milk I mean this was their
advertising campaign before clearly
didn't have that big in effect but with
the catchphrase of only two words got
milk
suddenly milk was hilarious milk
if Santa didn't get some with his
cookies he'd steal your freaking tree
think you've died and gone to heaven
not when you have giant cookies and no
cartons of milk to wash it down with
got milk the best ones often tricked you
so you didn't even know you were
watching a milk commercial until the
very end one of them you think is an
Oreo commercial trying to find a name
for the product cookie but when an
advertiser wants to drink down his
mouthful
what about you Hurley well my mech is
wasn't it good that he didn't have milk
still better than this another it's
particularly cruel making you think it's
a tricks commercial different kids
oh that hurts so good
next time try a better costume than
Kenny from half-baked these ads were so
popular they were even being mentioned
by God milk
CGV ginger China's but by far the best
is the one that started it all an
obsessed fan of Alexander Hamilton and
still obsessed makes a peanut butter
sandwich when a radio calling contest
asks for $10,000 who shot it
who shot Alexander Hamilton in that
famous duel all right let's go to the
phones and say who's out there mm-hmm
ohh for $10,000 whoa excuse me I'm sorry
[Music]
got milk my god is that brilliant by far
the greatest got milk commercial and
probably one of the greatest commercials
of all time I mean it's absolutely
genius who L directed that no no that's
right critic your Bey we heavenly Christ
you directed this masterpiece oh sure
but I don't really see it as a
masterpiece how can't you it's one of
the most famous commercials of all time
yeah but that was the old bay the one
that still put out quality and new
things
today's Bay would just do the usual shit
in fact in honor of its 24th anniversary
very random number lively shot the
commercial to reflect my current style
you didn't I did you broke what wasn't
broken
I prefer blew up at both work take a
look that was annoying boy says no no no
no no for two hours and now for today's
sexy question who was responsible for
writing The Legend of King Arthur
I know the answer it was transformers
covering up a trunk Merlin oh that's so
correct you win
[Music]
now I'll shower and milk against a
blazing sunset in slo-mo give me a sec
but a drink of Bud Light
what white is awesome so not only did
that make no sense but you let a product
placement get in the way of another
product placement oh you're too kind I'm
just gonna pretend in a parallel
universe you're listening to me I've
been giving that a lot lately
well even though times change great
commercials always last oh no this was
an ad for a department store called
zellers and well it's cool to get Batman
and Robin in there the way they're
represented is kind of odd attention
attention family thanks honey time
prizes on Joe okay I don't know why the
pet Cape has an announcer but he does
not sound very excited to be said
announcer I won't be ecstatic if Batman
pick me for that job you unenthusiastic
dick punchline Joker
Wow I know the Joker's supposed to be
excitable but hummingbirds made out of
jell-o don't move like that Julian I'm
all cartilage listen only until is are
you protected by and what's up with
Batman's voice it sounds more like his
grandpa on 1920s radio he's pulling a 20
to schedule bully observers are you
protected by the law of Toyland nobody
keeps sellers prices on toys nobody yeah
that's great
is this crime really Batman or Joker
worthy I feel like this was at the lower
end of anarchy and chaos
Hot Wheels are just a dollar seventy
seven each next I'll tell them that
Walmart's prices are suitable at best
suitable the weirdest right instead be
animation closeout what was already a
surreal bat experience you're protected
at sellers because the lowest price is
the law my imaginary spine I don't have
odd to say the least but still contains
a lot of energy for a few yolks
holy one-liner Batman what it's zellers
Robin they bring in his a material to
this move The Pretenders here's a cute
idea I think honestly it's kind of weird
they're the PERT Enders cats that can't
get adopted so they disguised themselves
as other animals you know because a
toucan and a duck have a better chance
of getting bought over a cat we had to
work with this dumbass pun this is the
best we could do in it brilliant isn't
it
just your basic ass - all you can get
anywhere but throw a two-cent mask on
him and suddenly there's a creeping
story I was blacklisted during the
McCarthy era the only buy scripts for me
if they think I'm a bunny cute how dumb
are you a mouse it's a cat
hey mice this was such a weak-ass idea
they had to downplay their toy
appearance and Burger King meals what do
you think it could be it might be
linguini linguini yeah pretenders would
be impressive if you thought you were
getting linguine
were you dropped the pretenders for fun
cats who pretend to be a dog a duck a
mouse and a bunny
honestly I prefer the linguini what are
you on a little too complicated for my
taste but I guess it's adorable
don't tell okay why are you help your
secret the pretenders from fisher-price
each sold separately bucket of rainbows
what the hell you know sweaty muscles in
front of dry ice can sell idiots
anything Oh trust me I know
check out this ad for an unimpressive
toy called the Eliminator a plastic
knife that doesn't cut hyped that is
literally the same thing I think your
sister in college will get better use
out of that than you yeah I have one of
those too it's called a flashlight it's
a flashlight again a flashlight I think
I'm putting together who this toy was
intended for you didn't even name 7/7
was complimenting yourself hello and
they're cheap Taiwan plastic one of the
we cast weapons are on that thing oh
it's the ice cream scoop the electric
toothbrush and the thing the father
tried to sell in gremlins cool
a little funny for its cheesiness but
still lame-ass toy if you can't find it
it's because it's also your mom's dildo
mr. Wolverton there's a mr. the Frog
here to see you mr. Warburton okay I
know the Muppets have had their ups and
downs in the past but what the hell are
they doing here is it true you're
bringing out a giant crumpet yes but
well sir you have given me a fantastic
idea for a muppet extravaganza a giant
crumpet that's giving you the idea for a
muppet extravaganza you ain't kidding
look at the size of this production
don't get me wrong it's impressive funny
and the Muppets are great but it's
freaking trumpets so it rhymes with
Muppet great it's still just a goddamn
British pastry it really doesn't deserve
this much attention imagine there was a
profit called humping condoms would they
be like our show Bob and so now we're
doing this some of it even seems out of
character like there's a friggin Muppet
death on screen watch it's not like a
safe falls on them real quick know
you've seen that thing struggle while
being devoured it's kind of gruesome oh
god no I'm the last of my kind
oh sweet Jesus that's where Skeeter want
it even ends on well kind of a raunchy
note okay I do not want to think of Miss
Piggy sexual assaults just because
you're a woman and a pig doesn't make it
any less Harvey Weinstein ich do pigs in
space now pigs in jail again the
commercials fine I guess but why float
this much money into a lavish production
for British crumpets have things really
gotten that bad for the Muppets crumpets
dungeon crumpets are you shitting me
Teletubbies my grandfather was an old
Jewish socket he came to this country to
uphold our the Frog name you don't give
me better deals you're letting a
generation of fabric down I see you want
me to think about it well think about
this Larry my banjo rainbow connecting
to what's left of your Oh Nancy
yes mr. f could you run down to beanies
and give me another six pack of hopping
frog beer don't you think you've had
enough mr. f I'll tell you when I've had
you washed-up bastard then do the
rainbow fade wow I can't really
depressing on that one didn't I well
here's hopefully a more chipper
commercial to make you feel better
you were still thinking about Kermit
weren't you look here's something more
chipper a delightful little donkey
little guy oh yes you um you're so
adorable they're just kind of keeping
the camera on you aren't they yeah just
really say anything then here are the
announcers guess they're just thank you
on your cuteness okay I can go with that
you're the cutie video guy oh yes please
give us a pound we'll have to pull the
trigger
[Music]
what and fluffy shit was that is this a
terrorist hostage video for Petsmart
this is even for our SPCA but let me
look that up an animal welfare charity
in Britain Wow of course when you're
doing crumpets you're all Muppets and
dancing but when you're doing PSA you're
telling dogs new Canada just listen to
the wording they use in this please give
us a pound
we'll have to pull the trigger are they
trying to get across the message that if
you give them the money they'll be able
to stop cruelty to animals was that what
they were trying to get across while you
failed miserably yeah it doesn't come
across that way at all they literally
say give us a pound or we'll pull the
trigger I would think this is a gritty
reboot of cats and dogs directed by
Christopher Nolan they don't even say
when RSPCA stands for it well in my mind
it stands for really shitty puppy
crucifying assholes this got such a
negative backlash that they cut down the
PSA and had a kid sing how much is that
doggy in the window while answering how
much a dog really does cost yeah don't
forget to include the funeral you sick
shits in fact that ironically
contradicts the last one they did where
this one says don't spend the cash if
you can't afford it the other one says
give us the cash or you'll see Benji's
brains okay I'm done with this one it's
horrible it doesn't get the point across
it's just disturbing please show me a
different one to watch
[Music]
okay come on come on maybe I won't think
of the PS a pound puppies pound give us
a pound or we'll pull the trigger
I'm sorry YouTube but I need time it's
the Mickey Mouse talking phone ah the
Mickey Mouse phone I think a lot of kids
at this kid you are way too young to be
into Mickey Mouse watching your body
also you sound relatively disinterested
in it to be fair it's better than this
obviously confused kid who says that to
a character phone that's like playing
Mario Brothers and saying this has
nothing to do with plumbing that was
Mickey Mouse huh sounds more like a
drunken old lady shouting obscenities
don't laugh at her it only makes her
drink more okay I sound nothing like
Snow White but I'm a woman that should
fool you at this age that was one of the
Martians from Mars Attacks three wrong
that's pretty impressive let's be honest
this project would be a lot more fun if
they brought in even more interesting
Disney characters I think there's a good
variety you can choose from by sexual
lust for gypsy girls half my age
birds like Harold's fire hello we're the
cast from Song of the South still a neat
idea for a toy just not advertised very
well Mickey Mouse talking fucking
batteries not included from
[Music]
Tiger looked arcade action in the palm
of your hand
I think that's a lie games like Mega Man
fight your way through eight stages and
play as you attempt to defeat the
villainous dr. wily Wow
what is this one whole bit games like
mm2 Billy Lee returns as you use your
incredible ninja acrobatic yeah what
acrobats are those extending one arm and
one leg while your dick magically
disappears look at this it's so lame
they have to focus on the kids moving
around because there's no excitement in
the game itself if you saw any kid
moving like this while playing a tiger
game you think he was having an
epileptic episode but beat the ultimate
villain the black gato bomb it's so
jacked up he gets excited about golf
yeah there's friggin golf but not just
any golf leads Robinho's fighting golf
so you know they mean the real shit
choose between two levels of difficulty
as you select your own golf clubs
control the strength of your swing and
the direction of the ball I'm already
asleep hearing these exciting selections
and this kid's hoppin all over the place
video excitement in the palm of your
hand yeah that looks like a Kipling
handheld Golf over there also available
to Batman afterburners super sprint and
five in the quest piss on those dates
this has lead Trevino's fighting dog and
yes your jealousy arouses me as you
completely hold of championship gold dum
ad for a dumb product nothing much to it
Tiger Ltd video games
video excitement in the palm of your
hand Hey look
ball sex sucked off a fire hydrant
that's too crazy for even me to make a
joke about it I don't think this could
get more abstractly perverted up spoke
too soon Ice Cube all sacks are where
it's at where it okay you know what
these commercials are innocent enough I
shouldn't read too many of you it's
immature and it's been done to death I
should really just grow the hell up so
let's move on to the next one game fun
for children and for adults it's
exciting on you make strategic offensive
and defensive moves then try to bust
your Kevin Spacey likes to play this one
more
[Music]
you know what you're doing I know what
that wink means you know what you're
doing you know it's be easier to get
through if the narrator didn't salivate
every time you talked about it buster
and for adults it's exciting to try to
bust your opponent's balls
oh here's tongue on that one a great new
game from ego you know what though
I think I did okay yeah every year
there's always a commercial like this
with heavy sexual innuendos and you know
what I think I stay pretty mature pat
myself on the back this year I'm patting
myself on the back I'm a bigger person
than I thought why don't you call the
new water no no no I am NOT saying a
thing I am NOT saying a thing you hear
me not a god damn word but you think way
too highly of me if you think I'm not
going to re-edit this in a humorous way
[Music]
that's anything
the Wunder boner drives it like that now
the word final verdict
who's the nadir is a fine commercial it
just has the misfortune of coming across
the wrong way I mean cut away your green
goblin dick
oh my god this Atari commercial is
amazing I really mean amazing it's
actually so good it's hard to believe
it's real
hey yeah you look like a real jerk I
already believe every commercial should
start off that way so what you doing
well Buffy Buffy 15 EUR and I are going
on a Sunday Drive oh no you ain't you're
gonna play
[Music]
I will
what even this pole position sure it's
bought actually looks really crappy I
don't care it's bought I have no idea
why an explosion changed the logo on
that sign then I don't care Oh pole
position
hi RuPaul
pause Deshawn
[Music]
Oh
sorry he'll bust your crap and leave
skid marks
oh my god that was amazing
that was so amazing it's like suburban
commando if it was Superman commando
it's just phenomenal the comedy the
energy the over-the-top 80s of it all is
pure perfection and I think at the heart
of it is that guy that punk ass narrator
he is just so aggressively random he
calls this dude a jerk and then he
rewards him and he's so hostile to this
quiet non-threatening family I have no
idea what this guy would do in everyday
situations all I can say is I want to
see this guy style of madness in every
commercial you look like real jerks so
what you doing oh well we're going to a
family meeting
you're fighting dinosaurs now hi watch
it
[Applause]
hey shark watch it down oh I just made
pie actually it sounds really nice
it's apple pie that's my favorite would
you like a slice please
that's delicious
oh thank you you're the secret
ingredients not to break down the boo
but I think I killed your entire family
what yeah I gave one to a t-rex of
skills and killed another one of the
melted another's in space I killed your
dog pretty much everything you cherish
does God well I'm sorry I get carried
away sometimes
but hey have you ever played Atari pole
position no it's a lot of fun you should
try it okay okay well I'm gonna go away
and be a voice you had really nice bye
sorry I killed your family it's really
good Wow again it went really dark on
that one
really dark I'm the Nostalgia Critic and
I don't know why I look forward to this
every year hello I'm the Nostalgia
Critic I remember it so you don't have
to well I'm back in my commercial garb
that must mean we're talking about
commercials but not just any commercials
in the Pepsi Nintendo oh you thought
mass marketing was insane
try mass marketing around Christmastime
many of these commercials are so popular
they repeat them every year how crazy is
that an ad campaign you don't even have
to change because people love the
nostalgia so much well I love nostalgia
too and that's why we're gonna count
down the top 12 best Christmas
commercials ever done why top 12 well
I'll tell you in song
the first reason
[Music]
most of us are familiar with the classic
anime is short the Snowman it was
surreal whimsical and beautifully
animated well a UK drink cold iron brew
did their own take on the classic short
and in this one it isn't just magic that
brings into life but the opening of the
refreshing drink it goes just like the
original even down to the singing boys
voice
[Music]
that is until the snowman wants a drink
of his brew
[Music]
the Snowman gets more and more pissed
off until he decides he's just done with
a little snot
[Music]
not only is the commercial funny but the
way it replicates the original short
from the animation to the music it's
definitely a loving parody one that
brings laughs as well as the nostalgic
feelings of why we love the original
unlike some other Christmas parody
commercials still run the bill up kid
[Music]
every commercial on this list has to be
good it just has to stand out as
something we relate to the holidays
well this enjoyably awkward commercial
certainly stands out and people are
making a tradition of watching it every
year now it's just a guy turning home
and his loved one making him some coffee
after being away in West Africa long way
from West Africa I brought you something
from far away she waited up all night
for him he playfully pretends he got the
wrong house he gets her a gift and she
lovingly puts the bow on him and says
here my present this year they're
brother and sister yep this is incest in
the what the figgy pudding degree now
don't get me wrong they don't surprise
you with it at the end in fact they make
it very clear in the opening I dare even
say uncomfortably clear I must have the
wrong house who just says that who
announces their connection to someone
when they opened the door sister
confused but even knowing that going in
and yes you can take that in a different
way their body language the way they
talk and just the all-around mood
indicates that they're a couple it's
beyond creepy don't believe me just
watch it with this music what are you
doing here my present this year
[Music]
this commercial has become so infamously
eerie if that parodies are popping up
all over the place
people love to mock how incestuously
bizarre it is the others and sisters
don't look at each other like that
okay whether you find it charming or
it's sure to get reaction every
Christmas
[Music]
who tasted nuts and honey mr. square
Pepa knees are of course hates Christmas
and says humbug to the choir outside but
it's the great taste of honey and nuts
that snaps him instantly back into the
Christmas mood
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow that all those girls are really
kicking themselves that they wasted an
entire night on this guy we didn't need
any visions or tombstones we just needed
the commanding military of General Mills
who knew it was that easy I love that
the B brings up honey nut cheerios and
Christmas together like it's some sort
of tradition everybody knows about to me
come on honey nut cheerios and Christmas
that go hand in hand like KFC and
Christmas in Japan besides we all know
the real cereal to bring out Christmas
and U is Christmas crunch its Yuletide
crack I tells ya it'll make the roof of
your mouth bleed for a week and we love
it it's still a really great ad lo with
great atmosphere and cold colors it'll
charm the Dickens into you
[Applause]
[Music]
philia
oh yeah I can't forget these scary sons
of bitches I don't know how many people
remember this ad but while most kids
were dreaming visions of sugarplums we
had these little hell spawns dancing
around in our heads not only were these
things but freaky as sin but their
jingle was so catchy that many people
reported ear bleeding's with the blood
spelling out the name Nestle so even
their bodily fluids know how to spell it
in with that catchy never very boys why
do these things only have teeth on their
bottom jaws they look like marshmallows
that can somehow bite into your soul and
don't look directly into those eyes Mike
Myers mast has more humanity to it and
just when do you think it couldn't get
any scarier they fill the whole screen
with them it's disturbing nightmare
inducing and all-around unforgettable
sleep well tonight dreaming of your
Christmas slippers coming to life and
trying to eat you new holiday wrapping
from Nestle messmate
I talked about this one before but by
god it deserves to be talked about again
it's crazy how much they showed this
commercial it was everywhere around
Christmastime
it's just Barney once again trying to
get Fred's Fruity Pebbles but Santa
beats him to it as it happens but Santa
says it's good to share and thus Fred
finally gives them a bowl tis the season
to be sharing praise this commercial of
course raises so many questions how can
they celebrate Christmas if Jesus isn't
born yet
what's the origins of caveman Santa
Claus how the hell is Dino a singer but
my biggest question I never noticed
before is why is Fred giving Santa an
Apple that in no way makes sense first
off it's cookies and milk but ok let's
say he switched it out and made it
fruity pebbles what the hell is it Apple
gonna add to anything you're giving him
that with grounded Froot Loops is the
idea that there's so little actual fruit
in it that giving him an Apple will
somehow make up for it I don't know but
what I do know is the commercials been
played so many times it has our
childhood by the balls or balls using
bowls right because how can fruity
pebbles be in our but you know don't
answer that Internet I said stop
regardless it's still a lot of fun Rudi
and cocoa pebbles cereals part of this
nutritious breakfast
[Music]
McDonald's has had a lot of great
Christmas ads one with the girl talking
about running away to McDonald and
another with a star that needs to be put
back in the sky she's gonna Santa Clause
the movie tie-in that must have paid off
but the one people seem to enjoy the
most is the skating on a bunch of kids
go to the nicest ice ring set they've
ever seen where they see a creepy ass
clown skating he takes them for a spin
but one kid is having trouble keeping up
the kid has left out rattle seems to
take off the deer makes fun of him but
then Ronald comes back picks him up and
gives him a magical moment because the
music indicates it's a magical moment
[Music]
I think it has the biggest impact
because there's no talking in it it's
nothing but music visuals that
bored-looking dear seriously what's his
story because of that that makes it a
bit more universal anyone can watch it
and immediately know what's going on and
feel the warm special feeling when a
stranger and clown makeup picks you up
and doesn't let you go the commercial
makes it sound a lot nicer than I do
it's a good ad that continues to bring a
smile to a lot of people's faces
[Music]
you
number six another and I've talked about
before but certainly deserves a spot in
the list in many respects it's not even
really a Christmas and Christmas is
never mentioned but the idea of a
snowman coming in from the cold getting
warmed up by soup how can this not lead
to a lot of warm fuzzies that connect
you with the holidays I think what makes
it work is the contrast it's not just
cold it's sideways snow cold and the
inside isn't just warm it's someone
throwing a Norman Rockwell painting on
the fireplace warm the two extremes
brought together equal the perfect mix
that leaves an impression on your
nostalgia Plus that damn impressive
puppet I mean they did a really good job
on that thing the only question I ever
had was how did he actually eat the soup
it always cuts away before we could see
it do the rocks open up do they form an
open mouth where does the soup go when
he needs to take a pic again Internet
don't answer that a great ad to make you
feel nice and cozy every time this one
just came out this year and already
people can't stop talking about it it's
one of the oddest Christmas commercials
to ever come out and that's saying
something we see a man in the mountains
recording something on his iPhone
he seems happy hanging pictures of n
jokes on his wall when he suddenly gets
up and goes down to the village in a
bizarre twist
it's the Frankenstein monster goddess
but that's not where it stops he goes in
front of the town tree and puts two
Christmas lights in his bolts clever but
it doesn't stop there he starts singing
there's no place like home for the
holidays
[Music]
um um but then one of his lights goes
out and everyone looks pissed
stupid Frankenstein monster I am so not
impressed by anything but then a girl
goes up fixes his light she starts
singing and then everyone starts singing
[Music]
what the hell was that
this was so strange so random so
bizarrely mixing whatever emotions we
can't describe in a pot of I don't know
it's so out there that in a strange way
you have to admire it it is so strange
but it clearly has a good heart too and
I think that kind of motion does shine
through and everyone else seems to think
so too
no ray has millions of hits on YouTube
just one day after it premiered and it's
still going strong it can't be explained
it just has to be seen so the next time
Raymond's brother tries to steal the
spotlight and people find it
uncomfortable just send a little kid in
to sing with him and subtly everyone
will find it cool Christmas we're trying
so hard to kind of make it Halloween
[Music]
coca-cola has been a trademark of
Christmas even down to Santa's red and
white outfit so it's no wonder that to
continuing commercials would tie the
spot here
one is the Santa packs it's just a dark
old night when subtly the Santa packs
jingle is heard people who put all their
love of the holidays and sugar liquid
syrup rejoice as the Santa trucks light
up the night boy is sad because I don't
know what a Coke is beamed into his
hands by creepy animated Santa and all
is right with the world the other one is
the coca-cola polar bears it's fight
because the first ant doesn't even make
a whole lot of sense it's just a bunch
of bears who watched the Northern Lights
drink a coke and that's it inspired but
the imagery was just so relaxing and so
for lack of a better word cool they had
to keep bringing them back every year
each has a story that usually went
nowhere but just looks so damn awesome
going nowhere they were visual
spectacles then and they're still visual
spectacles now so that's why today both
Santa and the polar bears are seen on
the coca-cola box both have nice winter
colors that make you feel the cold but
also appreciate it at the same time
seeing how these ads are still going
today coke definitely means it when they
say always
[Music]
if not out a nostalgic obligation it's
perhaps out of pure stubborn dedication
that this one makes the list the Hershey
Kisses ringing wish you a Merry
Christmas is hershey's longest-running
ad debuting in 1989 and still going
strong today to make the story behind it
even more interesting the brand manager
John Dunn was tasked with making several
whimsical Hershey commercials but was
told not to do a Christmas one but he
liked this idea so much and knew would
be a hit that he did it anyway and we're
still thankful in hindsight it's not
much it's disgustingly simple but maybe
that's why it lasts it is simple anyone
can see it giggle feel good afterwards
it's not trying to be too big or too
sentimental it's just a little happy
moment not unlike a little Hershey kiss
chocolate it makes perfect sense to
Sandy more would ruin its simplicity
which honestly speaks for itself
so we'll just leave it as it is
[Applause]
[Music]
another one that makes the rounds every
Christmas and another one that seems so
disgustingly simple the M&Ms are setting
up red and green M&Ms for Santa
which seems cannibalistic the more I
think about it when Santa appears and
they both pass out the M&Ms were always
popular commercials but they hit a big
when they were given individual
personalities suddenly the M&Ms were as
popular as Disney or Warner Brothers
cartoons we knew who they were and loved
them
thus we look forward every year to
seeing them interact with Santa the same
way it's just a reminder how far
marketing can come turning hardshell
chocolates into classic cartoon
characters we never get tired of
watching them and we look forward to
seeing this one several Christmases more
what can you say but you don't mess with
the classic Santa now before we get to
number one here are a few runners-up the
Budweiser horses some connect this to
Christmas so why not edica a grandpa
tries dying just to get the family
together that's pretty ballsy but not as
ballsy as Kmart's jingle bells just for
the shock that they got away with this
at all
Santa Anna norelco razor an oldie but a
goodie Amazon Prime's commercial were a
real priest and a Mon me 40 showing
unity and religions and staples creating
an insane snowman robot pretty hard not
to get a laugh here but all right let's
get to number one and the number one
Christmas commercial is
[Music]
oh yeah you better believe I'm doing
this to you
Sainsbury has done a lot of emotional
commercials in the past the majority of
them get millions of hits on YouTube but
the one that has to be the most powerful
has to be the 2014 ad because it's based
on an unbelievable true story in 1914 on
Christmas during World War one
battling sides decided to put aside
their differences stop killing each
other and go out in a sign of peace for
one day they suddenly went from trying
to kill one another to treating each
other like brothers they shared stories
treats presents anything they had to
make the ad even more powerful it was
released exactly 100 years after the
event took place they actually tried so
hard to get this right that they teamed
up with the Royal British Legion to get
the details down there's even a making
of the commercial on YouTube to show how
hard they tried to get it the chocolate
bar as well was sold in stores and the
profits all went to the Royal British
Legion to benefit their armed forces and
their families this ads so easily could
have come across as manipulative or even
corny but they did everything in their
power to make sure the proud message of
that night wasn't lost
it's a powerful commercial that
represents a powerful point in history
now their effort doesn't go unrecognized
and when you watch it all you can think
is yeah that's what Christmas is all
about
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm the Nostalgia Critic let's remember
together
you